Thanks buddy.
Bye there.
We started guns.
We do really good ads again,
man.
Listen folks,
I'm a retard because I'm a little tech friend.
My technologically enhanced friend.
Yeah.
I don't know how the fuck to do this.
I'm just winging this shit son.
It's the bath.
Just guessing and flipping cue.
You were able to fade the song out.
Yeah,
I did a good job with that.
Let me make sure that if I switched to this view that we people still here.
It
still here.
Whoa.
That's me.
I'm a retard grom.
He's just done another system.
All retarded person.
I trust me.
I'm,
I get an argument with someone in the middle of argument.
They think of what's seven times 40 and I'm like,
I don't fucking know.
I'm,
we're upset at each other.
I can't do math.
I fuck you asked me to do man.
What kind of tricks it,
they tried to make me think I'm stupid.
It was like mission accomplished.
I don't know.
There's a lot of numbers.
I'm done with numbers,
dude.
I'm really done with numbers.
Yeah.
I have to really force myself because when I was a kid I just had really bad
times in math.
I thought it was so boring.
I had a terrible attitude about it and I never had anybody who was like an
enthusiastic math teacher and my teachers would not terrible,
terrible teachers.
They just were bored.
They just were uninspired,
you know?
They weren't really into it.
Like I remember one time there was a documentary on about Lake Erie and it was
just one crazy science professor or in our class science teacher,
I guess Mr. Holman and he was always like late with the facts.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I just always like,
you know some shit that was true like a while ago.
He,
he would not be like kept up to it this,
oh this,
this thing was,
and he just kept saying,
he kind of,
yeah,
it was about Lake Erie.
There was like the world's no around.
It's oval there he was insisting that Lake Erie was a dying lake and I said,
really?
Yeah,
well you know a dead lake because Lake Erie really is because it's going to dry
up.
He can know really badly polluted.
Um,
but no life in it.
Yeah.
I think Lake Erie had to make a big comeback but they,
they cleaned it up and this was that.
There was a whole documentary that was on PBS like really recently,
like in the night before and me and another kid in the class,
we're talking about the documentary.
I was like what?
We just saw something on PBS that said it's making its comeback.
Shirley's fisherman and they show the exact some guy who went to school 40 years
ago but he didn't even listen to us.
He dismissed it.
He didn't want to talk about it.
He didn't acknowledge that maybe there was some possibly some new data that he
had been like teaching some shit that somebody figured out in 1980 or something
and then this is some new back then if you weren't really like on top of shit
you like really on top of what the fuck is going on in the news.
If you're free balling on stage in front of the class telling people that and
that's why Lake Erie is a dead lake.
And then some kid goes,
no,
it's not dead.
They,
there
was a whole documentary on TV,
man.
And he said,
fuck you.
No,
we didn't listen.
He didn't want to even,
he didn't even want to acknowledge it.
Whereas like if you said that to me,
if you said there was a whole dot,
if I was saying,
obviously I'm,
where did you hear that?
I'm not,
obviously I'm not a fucking teacher,
but if,
you know,
if,
if you,
for whatever reason we're talking to me about that and you,
you brought up that PBS ran a whole documentary on it,
I would have to go,
Ooh,
I didn't see that.
I would have to go,
oh wow,
there's this new stuff.
Maybe this one improvement.
So that's good news.
It's good news and science can actually clean up the ocean and the rivers and
the lakes as well as faculty.
Surprise to hear it.
Yeah.
It's nice.
Well,
it is beautiful that they have made some pretty significant,
um,
uh,
they have had some pretty significant results and cleaning up some types of
spills and they've introduced have,
they've come up with new types of bacteria that actually eat oil and can help
clean up places like the Gulf and situations like that.
You know what I heard about that pile of plastic,
they always talk about when they say how big is it?
Like twice the size of Texas.
They said that's such a humongously gross exaggeration.
Well it's less than one 100th of the size of Texas real.
And they said that that kind of exaggeration discredits the actual problem
that's there cause it makes people write off everything.
It's humongous.
But Texas is massive.
Right?
So they're just being like typical liberals.
Anyone wants to like make sure everyone knows about it.
Yeah,
well it's like I held my breath for 10 seconds.
Like oh that's a long time.
Like someone else would want.
So we like,
I held my breath for five minutes and you're like,
no you didn't.
You went too far.
Well you can do that.
There was a guy,
I'm the David Blaine Guy I think holds a world record minutes.
Oh,
more than that.
What?
Yeah,
more than that.
I think he did something crazy like 13 or 14 minutes.
Really?
He,
um,
he held,
he's got the world record.
I'm pretty sure the reason,
I know that sounds crazy.
It's like a train.
It's 13 or 14 minutes.
So stupid.
You don't know where I'm getting this from.
Brian Cowen.
Oh really?
Fucking love Brunch.
And he had a hawk on the shoulder the whole time.
Right counts.
Piece of beautiful person.
I couldn't love that dude.
Um,
it might be true though because David Blaine's David blank column,
magician calling whatever the fuck you want to do.
I will call David Blaine a bad motherfucker.
Okay.
Cause I couldn't stand that ice first ones that everybody in the new one or the
old one who's the crazy guy that would like hang out in a box and you know,
supply.
No.
Did he,
did he do something like that?
Somebody did that.
He doesn't take it.
That's the type of guy that would make the statue of liberty disappear
holding Breck,
somebody's Aruba for fucking however long breath world record.
13 or 14 I mean nuts.
I couldn't do it for 30 seconds.
Yeah,
I'm not so good at holding my breath.
You know what Brian and my time are.
We though that was one of the greatest things that anybody's ever said.
Oh,
okay.
17 and all my God.
17 and a half minutes.
No,
no.
17 minutes.
Four and a half seconds.
Holy Shit.
How long did it for?
Yes.
Oh my God.
This is insane,
man.
How the fuck did he do that?
That that's not just kind of crazy to think of held long like the time is
between like a sitcom scene starting and then they go to commercial.
How many is that?
How many minutes is that?
Is that seven minutes or something like that?
Two of those dude plus some.
That's a long time.
Think of like an episode of friends,
like two of those things that held the fucking crazy.
I'm Marcia.
Oh my God.
Well before they go to commercial,
Turner,
Turner.
Think of that.
He's held his breath through that whole thing and then some two are those?
Yes.
Well that was just 40 seconds.
That seemed like forever.
Yeah.
He's a weird man.
Um,
he,
yeah,
he goes all the way through the first break and the second break.
If that guy was a fighter,
he would be a scary guy.
They've a blend.
You ever see black people react to him?
No.
It's hilarious.
What do they do?
Black people still have a weird thing about magic.
Um,
and they react like,
no,
no.
They push each other and shove and run away because they have weird thing.
They can just can't say like it's a trick.
They feel strange about it.
It's hilarious.
Wow.
Lots of very scared of his magic.
That scared the scare of magic in general.
Really.
That's a racist thing to say.
Ours.
Your fear.
We're scared.
Observation.
What?
I grew up with elders teaching me that black people are scared of magic.
I watched,
by the way,
I learned a Jewish,
a horror movie the other day.
What was it?
That girl was pretty,
now this new movie.
The,
um,
what the fuck is it called?
The possession or some shit.
Like the box.
Yes.
You saw that.
Did you realize a small part in it?
Yeah.
It was fucking good.
But about the holding up a fucking evil spirit.
It's a box.
That was a good horror movie,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
I mean it was no,
apocalypse now was a fun horror movie.
I enjoy the shit out of it.
The dude from the watchman that looks like Brad Garrett,
but he's not Brad Garrett.
Here's what I got to start doing.
Yeah,
I know that guy.
Here's what I started doing it and I start going to movies and saying,
this is just supposed to be dumb fun.
That's all this is supposed to be,
right?
Yeah.
Expendables or whatever you call him down for.
I'm down for like the Avengers and Werewolf movie.
Let's root for the good guys that don't worry about it and I'll fuck around and
see a twilight movie with Mrs Rogan.
I very crazy just for a grill.
It's just to find out why the fuck is going on.
I'm going to go see 50 shades of gray to just to find out what the fuck is going
on with the sex book.
Right.
It's,
yeah.
There's something going on with us,
man.
Here's what a not getting our rocks off girl.
Yeah.
Girls want the porn just like we want it,
but theirs is not what we want.
There's a romance porn.
There's a,
there's a different kind of porn.
There's a vampire who will risk everything just to be with them.
You know guys?
Yeah,
exactly.
My mom,
you know,
I've had this farm down there,
special power of had conversations with a bunch of different people about this.
What every girl's like,
I don't want that kind of left too.
It was like,
well,
you don't get that.
You don't get that kind of love.
That's not real.
There's still van buyers always get off the path.
Isn't that nuts?
Somebody told me this is to,
so it was like,
wait,
so that kid has been around someone who told me this,
that guy,
he's been around for 2000 years and he's in love with a 16 year old.
Exactly.
Those ummy.
Oh,
it was fucking pervert.
Shit.
Thousand year old dude hanging out with 17 year old girl.
That was me.
I know.
Yeah.
It's like ridiculous.
It's so stupid.
It's just stupid idea that he would still be in high school.
He's going to give up his power.
He's got to pretend he's in high school.
[inaudible]
high school.
Well,
you can pretend you're 18 you're out of school.
Yeah.
Pretend that you look like you're 25 you can pass it to the street.
You got to show up at school every day like everybody else a little bit.
Greg,
your hair and go to a bar and hang out at night with regular people.
Regular things.
Shave your head stupid.
What?
They get your references about the count.
Yeah.
You don't have to tell people you're 17 you look like you're 25 go.
Just go.
Go leave school.
You can graduate this year.
What nonsense is that?
He's got to keep enrolling in school.
The truant officer are gonna kind of stop a vampire for running around.
Oh,
family van part that only eat deer in the fuck are you saying you got nice
people?
Vampires at run around eating deers and those movies,
let me answer your question.
And those movies,
do they already know everything that's being taught in the school?
Yeah.
Learned those times though.
The white,
the Maytag guy sit there.
That's like a some sort of a crazy like torture.
Yeah,
like Chinese water torture porn or on,
it's no big deal.
But if water keeps tripping on you for a hundred hours,
you might lose your fucking marble.
Like groundhog day.
Yeah.
You might go crazy by the year.
What the fuck?
What are you transfer schools every,
every two years?
Fucking vampire that doesn't bite you.
What are you talking about?
I want my cake and eat it too.
I want that kind of love.
I want to be a stay at home mom and have a career.
This is why it sounds better.
That sounds like a crazy while you're not equals I want to fly and be a person.
Well you better get a plane bitch cause you can't do that shit with your body
can't really fly and that's crazy.
How can you want that?
What do we want below job to release the release from the,
the,
the junkie of the penis.
The penis that wants to explode squirty stuff out.
Yeah.
Those movies were Warner for all of us.
They ruin it for all of us.
What?
Porn movies?
No,
not put the girl porn movies.
The other girl,
but they don't know.
But they're like,
I sort of expect something better now.
Well No,
they're just responding to a lack of romance.
You know,
there's a lot of people that don't find anybody who's really into them.
it's fucking hard to find someone who just,
well,
you're exactly what they're looking for and they're exactly what you're looking
for.
Cause a lot of times it's just one,
one of one of those is there,
like I said to the girl or the gores girls or the guy or you know,
someone's annoying and whatever the fuck it is,
it's exactly what anybody is looking for.
And what do you,
that's so not true,
dude.
I know people,
it's rare as fuck thing.
Not even like,
I wish they put their socks away more.
I wish they were a little more,
that's a crazy person worrying about socks.
What are you doing to say crazy example?
He gets to the bottom.
Mr Chef,
she has problem.
He's British trying already to sabotage with clothing.
Nothing.
It has to do with behavior.
It's all closing now.
That sounds like the guy that Donald Duck,
I remember the old cartoon with a Donald Duck like scientists when he was
talking about the road rage that happens with you.
Remember that one and he goes,
does the driver gets in the car and it just turned into this thing?
Yes.
Yeah.
He's like a scientist duck.
A scientist stuck.
That's right.
You sounded just like that.
I haven't thought about that kind of,
I can never do that voice again.
It's lost.
It's in.
Why you won't be able to reproduce it.
I can only do like a couple of voices like confidently and I have to be around
them all the time.
Like Chilean only is,
I'm around Joey Diaz all the time so I can do Joey Diaz easy.
Other ones like that.
I had him for a while and then they're gone.
You know,
you know like Arnold Zz,
you could do Arno Dz.
It's Arnold.
He's the only guy you can do with just noises.
You could usually,
you know,
it's so dumb,
but like
I've never seen that not work on stage.
Yeah.
It's so dumb.
It's a noise,
but it's that guy.
Yeah.
Where's it?
I don't think that's the QC.
I don't,
can't think of any.
Maybe Stallone.
I guess
this is more like,
there's like a little bit of an annoyance.
Yeah.
There's so many movies where he was yelling what you're like,
what the fuck is he on?
Like that for and normal person be like,
and he's like
the most bizarre.
Like did you see the remake of a,
of a,
where's the Kona spot here?
No,
not Conan.
Where's the sweet spot?
Do wherever you're fucking beautiful face makeup.
It's a sweet spot right there.
Total recall?
No,
just out of respect.
Yeah.
I already got Joey Diaz for seeing the new version of the mechanic.
Rarely led is almost stabbed me real a Spec for Charles Bronson dog.
You go to that fucking piece of shit.
That fucking Jason stayed on that little pansy.
He's going to play Charles Bronson's character cock sucker went with,
he went crazy.
That fucking movie.
It was very good.
I bet it was one of the coolest guys.
I love state though and I loved that dude who,
I don't remember his name,
but he was in,
um,
he was in that movie,
the vampire movie about a Alaska Fan Perry movie.
Oh wait,
it's all night long.
They might last six months,
30 days of light or something like that.
60 days at night,
90 days,
90 days.
120 days.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
The vampire or whatever,
the fucking vet.
Somebody on Twitter was screaming at me.
I'm sure.
Ron,
how are you the one who gets to talk,
Charles back as per toasty for six months,
but a,
he was a bad ass in that fucking movie that,
that Vamp,
30 days of night.
You got it.
The first guest,
that movie,
I got to find out this dude's name now because he,
he was so fucking good in that movie.
It was chilling because it's such a stupid premise that you're an a vampires.
It's sort of cool.
Vampires would go with this more note,
but these were legit,
I'm sorry.
Hold on a second.
These are legit.
What vampires are legit fan part?
This is one of the last movie,
30 days of night where they were fucking terrifying.
Legit vampires.
They were awesome.
And why couldn't they find those people?
Why can't they go to door to door?
Um,
kept,
they didn't want to come early really into looking at hard.
I mean,
yeah,
they had a hideaway and go from place to place this news.
How many Houston is homeboy's name?
That's one of them.
He,
this guy played the vampire.
Oh really?
Yeah.
This guy was one of the guys in that movie that was awesome.
But he wasn't the guy that I was thinking about.
There's a full cast and crew.
There's a guy who played like the vampire familiar.
He paid,
played like the familiar scent.
Yeah.
The person that was hoping they were going to turn him into a vampire.
A,
yeah.
Yeah.
That guy never works out for him.
Right.
Oh yeah,
it never works out.
That guy always gets chat,
so he's kind of a piece of shit,
you know?
There's always something wrong with them,
but he ain't familiar.
But he's such a good weasel.
No,
and in this movie he had like rotten teeth and he was all fucked up looking.
Really?
Yeah,
it was awesome.
He was great.
They didn't allow him to have a,
they always kill those guys.
Yeah,
they did it in the hunger games too.
Oh yeah.
You got to kill those cow to kill him eventually.
I don't let those guys fucking go on.
Ben Foster,
that's his name.
That guy.
Yeah,
he's from Boston.
Holla at your boy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
That,
that dude is a bad motherfucker.
He's keeping an eye on that dude.
As far as like,
like watching a guy that can really pull off someone fucked up in a movie.
Holy Shit.
Is he good?
He sees the familiar,
the familiar.
He was so good in it.
It was like this is silly role.
I mean you got to pretend then they couldn't change.
It seems so stupid.
But he did it so creepy and so fucked up that he looked like a guy who had been
so shell shocked before they put him in this prison.
He was so shell shocked because he had seen like just vampires,
just gutting people.
Everywhere he went,
they were going to turn him into a vampire in it and eventually they just
spoiler alert.
Eventually they fucking eat his face and it's pretty intense.
But you buy it.
He's his,
his raw acting.
He's the of it all
after.
Do they like slow?
They fuck you up man.
These are scary van or ways to do that fucking shit with the animals.
Yeah,
like a wolf would eat your face.
You know wolf would and your face like a panther would eat your food.
It's nice I'm into it.
But other vampire can,
you could just drink a little their blood and you have to drink a little.
Supposedly they all make their own rules.
Now.
Vampires can go outside in the day.
Oh yeah,
blade started with that shit.
Remember that?
They put soil screen on that dude on black laid black blade.
They put sunscreen and the other dude on the outside,
he could walk with what is the handsome fella doesn't work that much anymore.
It was in that,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
He was in three girls.
Two girls.
A pizza place.
Two girls that go on a pizza place.
Was he in that one too?
Yeah.
Devastatingly.
Stephen Dorff.
Is that him?
Yeah.
Oh,
that guy.
That guy was out.
Handsome fellow.
Stephen Dorff and he was one.
It's got a beautiful face,
but anyway,
all he had to do is put this sunscreen on and he was okay.
He was protected from the fucking the sun.
Rarely.
That's nonsense.
Vampires couldn't figure that out.
Come on,
man.
Vampires would go outside it.
Fucking authors in the spring lasts like 45 minutes.
Come on,
man,
you're going to put some fucking sunscreen on.
You're not going to burst into flames.
You're treating me like I'm an asshole.
Do you know that sunscreen companies just revolted against the America had to
make him put widget stuff on their bottles.
Why were they doing just lying about second waterproof SPF was were were ranges
sang.
It's waterproof.
It's paint by the way.
It's paint,
it's paint.
You're going to want your fucking head.
It's like,
no you're not.
It's not waterproof.
It,
it'll come off in the water.
Putting words like sport on there to make you think like,
oh I can just have this on for hours and you're like,
you're making people get skin cancer.
I developed some real problems with sensitive eyes because of sunscreen really.
Cause I had to use sunscreen so much on fear factor when I did fear factors are
outside all the time.
When I first started doing it,
like I try like a retard.
I didn't wear sunscreen like the first couple of days that I ever worked at.
I was just outside just getting cooked.
Um,
I got like really fucking burnt.
So I was like,
all right,
I got to wear sunscreen.
So I was wearing sunscreen like three and four days a week.
Standing outside while they shit drips in your eyes when whenever you get any
kind of sweat and it's thing and you know,
a lot of times it's,
it's a sweaty day,
you know,
like it's really possible for sh little bit of a the chemical to get you know,
moisture and it just drips into the corners of your eyes.
Then it would sting like a motherfucker.
Sometimes I would go on stage at the store and I forgot that I had sunscreen on
my forehead so I would sweat and then while I was on stage sweating,
it would drip into my eyes and it would be horrific man.
It would be like my eyes are getting burned.
Like I was getting chemical burns in my eyes and because of that,
like I've had like problems,
like swimming doesn't feel the same way in the ocean anymore.
It's like much,
yeah,
it's much more painful than it used to be.
Like swimming,
swimming in the ocean.
It's like,
wow,
like this fucking stings.
We're swimming in like freshwater.
It's like no problem at all.
And that to me,
the salt,
the fact that the salts things,
it's like male.
It feels like maybe may have been some damage there.
So like also when you're swimming in and it comes up,
then it runs into your face a lot more to your eyes.
What's just the fact that it gets in your eyes,
you know?
So what does it do he now,
what are your eyes like if they weren't staying?
Are they staying?
If I get in the salt water,
which did morsel.
Yeah,
more so than when I was younger.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm pretty sure it has something to do with being burned.
A few times it,
it at least three times it was really painful or I got really burned,
like legitimately it hurt.
Oh yeah,
like on stage it's crying.
I'm crying and you don't realize,
man,
that will sting.
Whoa,
I'm a pussy.
No,
no.
The other way.
I mean,
you don't ever react to it.
I was like,
what's up bro?
I got so upset that pussy,
no,
your,
I would expect if you were in high school with me,
you would have in one of those kids that came in just hand over a flame.
No,
I don't want pain.
I just,
but I,
um,
I've,
I've been pretty good at shutting it out.
Like,
uh,
like getting tattooed.
You have to shut it out.
It's not that hard,
man.
I almost fainted.
Oh my God really didn't even an hour.
It just pinchy I was with Bella.
Remember Bella Bella Giulia [inaudible] sure.
Yeah.
We went to get him and uh,
she got one and I got one and it was like,
you've got a way harder spot than I do gas.
No Way.
There's no sleeve.
Yeah.
I'm telling you that side area is brutal.
It's just one of the most sensitive areas.
I Dunno why it's supposed to be super sensitive,
especially like the ribs apparently if you get the rep to the ribs because tone
is right underneath the fuck are you feel like rattling your rib cage with pain
just
really right over the bone and you're like,
oh,
Jesus.
The top heard described.
There's a few spots.
When I was getting my uh,
left sleeve,
my rights leave is only like probably like 60% right now.
I've got to go to Aaron del of a dove Ad Guru Tattoo in San Diego.
Holla at your boy.
I want to finish this.
We saw she won my,
what's it called?
My monk.
What?
It was it monkey.
I have a t shirt from them.
Oh,
that's right.
Funky gone.
That's what it does.
Yeah.
They have a lot of great artists.
San Diego is such a fucking cool town.
That's,
that's a good place to go and start a cult.
Maybe we should start our colony in San Diego.
It's not too far from La.
If you really had to be here for an hour later in the road.
Whoa.
Crank.
That might've been,
I'm full of Shit.
Fair.
Yeah.
That's a nice place to get laid in.
La Jolla.
Ooh.
Yeah.
How beautiful.
As long as the coach me through the science,
it wasn't me.
You're an ignorant or something out there or something.
I think the anger was on or I don't,
it was outside of the show was still going on.
Right.
If some girl said something to me like,
Oh,
you were really funny,
and then went outside to smoke,
that's where I was still smoking and you're looking to go get her number.
I was like,
no,
could I have?
You're like,
yes.
I was like,
really?
Yeah.
You were on the hunt and that girl came up and totally made the first move.
I couldn't read it.
Yeah,
and you went on stage and you talked about not having a girlfriend.
You were like,
all green lights ahead.
You know you were dirty as far as God dammit,
but you killed and that's what's important.
Killed you are the fucking man for whatever it was.
20 minutes you were the man.
She's like,
oh my God.
I'm just thinking about that.
You were like,
Oh,
you guys are showcasing here for warmth.
Yeah,
and go out there.
go get some sun.
I was so nervous too.
I was like,
okay,
I want to talk to him like,
she was like,
yeah,
sure.
Isn't it weird how you get like more comfortable like meeting New People.
Is there any experience?
I used to get nervous when I would go to a bank teller.
This is by the way,
when you were what?
Like 17 or 18 when I already fought in martial arts tournaments.
I didn't,
I mean I got scared of that too,
but I would,
I would be,
I wouldn't be tongue tied and nervous when I was going to talk to the teller and
a new person maybe that maybe a person of authority.
I just,
I just would get weird talking to people when I went for like long periods of
time.
Just training and not talking to people too much.
I got,
I got like real weird social anxiety shit really for awhile.
Yeah.
I got real weird.
Imagine that now for sure.
But if somebody like introduce you to somebody,
well I was very,
uh,
I mean I was still pretty confident in myself,
you know,
like unreasonably confident in myself because of my martial arts stuff.
But I was still like really weird with people socially.
Like I would,
I would get nervous talking to them.
Anybody.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
I didn't grow up feeling like,
uh,
the most appreciated person.
So a lot of times when I was a fourth round,
yeah.
So it was around someone new,
I would like,
think they're going to judge me and Oh,
where,
you know how long before this guy starts picking on me,
you know,
how long before this person starts,
how long before he finds out that I'm supposed to be cooking on a loser.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That's,
and when you feel like that,
you know,
as a young person growing up,
it's like,
it's super easy to have yourself fall into those situations.
So I would get like soup.
I could imagine it now.
Like now when I go to the bank,
I look forward to saying hi to the lady and uh,
you know,
I look forward to going,
hello,
how you doing?
Everything go,
what's up?
You know,
I think that there's like,
like yesterday you got to get a little discussion with people.
I learned that if you can do that,
you know,
if you find someone who really will have a nice little quick little nice
conversation,
you both feel good,
everybody feels good or you can just be that selfish,
senseless asshole.
Just can I help you?
What do you need?
Write it down.
That's not it.
You're a robot,
you know,
just interact with people all day.
You know,
maybe it would be fun if Joey Diaz worked at a fucking post office box place.
You'd be,
it's fun places to call the post office people.
They told me once how to do it like separate stuff and I do it every time.
They'll stop and come over like,
oh you got this shit man.
You got more used to Everett.
Thank you.
Dot Ireland.
You know,
Eddie Bravo used to work at ups sort boxes.
Like,
like there would be like a,
uh,
like he would stand next to these runways and the boxes would come at him and he
would grab the boxes and have to chuck them into like different places that
correspond to different like Laverne and Shirley,
like different area codes or zip codes rather.
Is it zip codes or note zip codes is the end of the letter.
Yeah.
So you had to like put them into different places.
Like what'd you say?
Like what show like Laverne and Shirley,
they do that with the bottles where they had to like,
oh,
that's right.
The end to do that with that pat would the brewery,
what was it called?
What was it?
No,
no,
it was a fake one,
right?
Shots.
Shots,
brewery.
Schlotzsky's.
That's a real one.
Fuck isn't man.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
That was a great show though when we were kids.
I think it's really,
really hard to watch now,
but answer me this,
what would show is that they're watching?
There's so many good female comedians from that era,
like cow Burnett and Laverne and Shirley.
They were like real legit shows that people wanted to watch Mary Tyler Moore.
I think it was maybe because of this I'm going to offer something that will
probably get me in trouble.
Okay.
But,
um,
I think it's because in those days,
Hollywood for the people in charge of choosing hadn't yet said we've got to find
prettier people.
The management system hadn't come in and promoted people from within to get
like,
well who do you have to choose from now?
A bunch of people,
they've told us these are who you had to choose from and you don't get like the
people who were just naturally talented to rise through the rice anymore.
If you look at sign live now,
most of those people are better looking now than when it started.
You know,
like everything has sort of changed and you're going to get prettier people to
look at,
which is nice,
but you're also not going to necessarily get the funniest or most talented,
most creative person that way.
Right.
You know?
And also Carol Burnett allowed everybody else to shine.
Yes.
And they had a super talented crew.
Is that thing falling apart on you,
man,
you keep fucking with it.
Now I'm trying to get to the right spot.
Don't touch it and it just leave it alone.
Yeah.
Caribbean Nan had a super talented crew.
It's just hard for us to recognize now because if you tried to watch the Carol
Burnett show right now,
I don't know if you'd really truly enjoy it.
I think I should go watch some of those because some of those I can live in
color.
You can't watch it all now.
Well,
like certain shows you cannot walk Bruce,
that Lenny Bruce [inaudible].
That's what you're looking at.
Yeah.
I was hitting on a point to that,
that Lenny Bruce posts that I have on my wall.
I'm a look.
I give it up to Lenny Bruce.
I think we all have to.
That was the originator.
That was the first guy.
If it wasn't for that guy,
it would have taken lots of notes to tends to get to this.
It would have taken him for what you and I do.
That guy is so super important.
But if you tried to watch his stuff today,
it's,
it's odd.
It's very strange.
There's one where he's on stage for over an hour reading legal documents because
the science should know just talking about the points of his case,
he went crazy because he was getting charged with obscenity and so he would go
on stage and read his fucking case.
He was the first one to suffer from that,
from thinking old famous.
He was,
he should be talking about.
Yeah.
He fucking fell apart because of it.
Cause we're,
it was a whole world.
The,
the,
the court cases.
And then on top of that,
the heroin,
you know,
he,
uh,
he was like severely depressed,
I'm sure because of a lot of it.
I mean,
all those guys that got arrested for saying things,
even a two live crew,
we owe them.
We owe them because if it,
if it wasn't for people who broke down the door with obscenity,
even though I don't,
I mean,
put some,
uh,
digging sigma as whole to me.
So it's,
I mean,
look,
I love it or hate it.
It's still,
it's a form of art.
Yeah.
But it's like,
it's this form of art.
It's like,
it's like,
why do you,
why do you choose to tell them not to say that?
Yeah.
That's what we believe in.
That they should be allowed to Susan,
who cares what it is?
If they like it,
what's it to you as the,
as long as they're not playing it in your face.
And,
and I don't think she'd be playing Beethoven in everybody's face,
either.
The section we bowed out of the Christians a little too much,
a little too much,
or like,
hey,
how about there's going to be some cursing on television.
So just research what you're going to watch.
And police are kids on your own?
Well,
Florida is so gangster.
We all want this.
Florida's got a leg,
a lot of really strange laws and uh,
some people like them,
but some people think that they're,
they're really nuts.
And this,
it was like four.
It has like a really large community of conservative people.
So they have some pretty strict laws when it comes to like pornography and
things like that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So when they have someone like say this guy,
you remember that dude who went,
went to jail for obscenity,
Max Hardcore.
He does like really intense shit.
Like really intense,
like shameful,
horrible things to people.
She's like pissing in her asshole and then they drink it with a straw.
Yeah,
like intense stuff.
Stuff.
Intense,
intense stuff.
Pissing in your mouth and you,
while he's got a hard on somehow or another.
And then he forces her head down and he pisses in her mouth some more and she's
gagging and throwing up pissed.
Yeah.
So what they did with this guys,
they decided to make a case out of him.
So they sent his stuff.
The Florida.
Yeah.
And then they sent it to some place that has very strict pornography laws.
And so that place was like,
okay,
well now we'll prosecute them based on our perception of what,
what types of different perceptions.
Yeah.
That's where it gets crazy.
And that's Florida who has like,
they didn't,
they run the math where people just go from spot to spot to spot Florida.
It's not mad hot or whatever it was.
It's a oxycontin's.
You could,
it'll do you just get a certain amount of every single city.
Yeah.
And they're trying to stop the A or slow the tide on the amount of prescriptions
that they give out.
But the fact is there's so many people that already have them.
So many people that are addicted to that stuff.
And if they all stopped cold Turkey,
they're all going to die.
So you've got to figure out how to get these people off this Zombie drug that
you guys have been making billions off.
Good luck.
You fucking assholes.
You crazy assholes that laid all your money.
Enjoy your yacht.
Even slave to population,
even slave to population with vampire dust.
We've turned people into zombies.
You know what they'll say?
What did they say?
Oh,
sorry.
Well,
um,
I just don't think about it.
They're going to stand right beside Mitt Romney.
He said,
we did build it.
We did build it.
You know,
everybody got mad at me because a,
I got mad at Obama for that expression that he used where he said,
you didn't build that,
you know,
to,
uh,
you didn't,
you didn't build the infrastructure and was talking about that,
you know,
the reason why we have,
such a great society that people are able to create jobs and start their own
businesses is because there's this infrastructure and you need to contribute to
that.
And you didn't,
you didn't build that.
You didn't,
you didn't,
you didn't build that infrastructure.
And that Mitt Romney that have the businesses,
he's saying that you didn't build it on your own.
Yeah.
But you know what?
I got upset about it.
Me and Brian Callen,
we're talking about it and I should clarify because enough people tweeted me and
comment about your own screwed.
Yeah.
It's what I,
what I don't like about that is because that,
that is a defeatist attitude.
You're telling someone something,
they didn't do it.
That's not how a leader should be communicating with people in my really
unsubstantial and completely irrefutable,
irrefutable position.
I mean,
to me
it's more what do you mean how a leader should act?
Those are,
those are,
those are things in terms that we grew up on,
but like what do you mean hang on his underwear and say whatever he wants.
I'm not saying that I don't start it any credibility on this subject,
but I think that when you're talking to a group of people,
this is just my opinion,
can't say that any of you have more times and if you're the leader of 300
million people and you're talking in negatives,
then you are putting out negative,
putting out negative energy,
your skulls and people.
You're,
you're in a sense you're saying that someone's wrong when you say you didn't
build that it about Mitt Romney,
but no,
he said that about people,
people that don't think that they should pay more in taxes.
People that don't think they should contribute more,
which I,
by the way,
and even though I'm,
I have a mixture of ideas that I have about what is I about?
I have a lot of things that I believe that a very liberal as far as like social
issues and a lot of things that I believe that are pretty conservative and
people would be kind of surprised because I just think there's a road,
there's a reality to human nature that a lot of liberal people I think don't
want to,
they don't want to accept they wanna.
They wanna pretend that people are a little less predictable than they actually
are.
Yeah.
You know,
but the she wins are humans react like this,
whatever type of spaces where you are.
Until we accept that all these conversations we have are just flavored by
bullshit.
We,
that's why political conversations never work.
That's why political speeches never would never see those sides than ever.
They've ever realize that you know when you want different things.
When you see a guy like Mitt Romney or a guy like Barack Obama,
who's,
by the way a really good speaker.
He's way better than I would be if I had to do that thing.
I'd get crazy emotional.
I'd probably cry with a bitch cause this was a really,
I had the real responsibility of guiding 300 million people.
He's and he handles it admirably.
I mean it's amazing but they all do it in a fake way.
They'll do it.
What we are,
the type of country that prevails.
We are not the type of country the backs down,
you know it's like you,
you're not talking to me as a,
as a human being and,
and these grandiose ways of using tone and separating speech is to me it's a lot
like standup halls for applause.
Yeah.
You can stand up jokes.
You hear them raise their voice at the top because of the message is cause the
way you delivered it.
Yeah.
He,
he used some theatrical type shit.
It's cheap comic doing that.
You're like,
come on,
I can't finish your set and go like this.
Go like,
give it up for me.
Some guys do though.
You've seen it.
How gross is that?
Remember there was a one guy that used to come around and would tell the
audience that I,
this always gets a standing ovation.
This is my last bid.
This always gets a standing ovation.
And he would go on to this last bit and then they letting them know at the end
of it he would tell people to stand the fuck up.
Stand the fuck up.
Standing
people are so crazy.
They're show greedy.
They want it.
It's mine.
It's my precious.
That's why the Gollum works so well cause everyone was like,
yeah,
I say that
it's become almost a hacky reference in comedy because it works so well because
it's,
it is like,
yeah,
that much desire for something that's the extreme,
the creepy as possible aspect of people.
It's when you're running into them in the midst of an addiction,
green monster.
When you see someone who wants something so bad,
you know that,
that,
that thing where I've seen it with coke,
I've seen it with people that uh,
that wanted coke.
But they just want to get back to where they were in the first 20 minutes of
their fucking coke trip.
Well,
they're not thinking.
They just know they want it.
They're just,
but it's,
it's weird to see that,
that glassy eyed like locked down on that chemical.
They want that chemical so bad.
I was with Tivo,
uh,
yesterday,
two days ago yesterday and we saw it when it happened.
Man,
it's hot.
Some guy crossing the street,
but he's walking with us sweatpants,
no t shirt and socks on,
walking down the Bray up pat crossing Hollywood boulevard.
And it was like on the other starts where I was like,
keep out.
What truck is that?
I think meth,
meth.
He to me Kinda mathy below the Mathy side,
Jesus Christ.
And I was like,
it seems calm.
He's like,
oh no,
he's just waiting for to get in his word.
That's why I have no respect for cops that decide by the way,
are forced to act.
But decide it's time to read medical marijuana dispensaries go cleaning up the
meth labs.
Yeah.
Fuck.
You know where people are,
what's worse going in and parking their car and paying for it with their credit
card and what's happening.
Yeah.
What's worse?
You assholes,
whoever it is at the top.
I know you're trying to protect your cops,
but really come on,
man.
You need to get drones.
And I usually don't say that,
but that's the cops need to deal with the math hung.
Yeah.
Just drones.
What's going to happen with the,
nothing's going to happen with the seat alone.
How about weed pays for drones to go after the math,
but the city council stuff for la,
that's not going to pass,
right?
No.
It's not going to pass.
Mayor's never gonna sign off now.
They can go fuck themselves.
The idea is ridiculous.
You all,
any they would lose,
they would lose billions of dollars in revenue,
in taxes.
It's ridiculous.
Those,
those companies are just as much of a legitimate business is someone telling Q
comp?
But here's the problem though.
Yeah.
But I agree with you.
But six out of seven,
um,
uh,
city councilman or whatever said,
yeah,
let's get rid of it.
Yeah.
There's,
those guys are bitches.
Are they in the pocket of people?
Is that what it is of core?
Is this is a big issue man.
If this could make,
look,
imagine you could wipe out just just for goof.
Say That you could wipe out all of the medical marijuana dispensaries in this,
in this state.
So the only way a patient could get pot was too illegally grow it.
If that was the case,
people,
people at Grandma's and shit that they would illegally or they would just go to
the pills.
It's very possible you get a lot of deals of pills.
Yeah.
A lot of people take it for pain relief man.
And a lot of people that have had like back injuries will tell you the craziest
shit.
The only story I heard where it's like a story,
evidence,
whatever that word is.
But um,
we were on that Moscow comedy tour that's Shitty wants AAA and all those guys
and this guy we'll see.
He was like,
no,
he was like,
he's like a a,
an army guys.
Like I'm not touching that stuff.
We've got a little annoyed.
He smoked around him within two weeks.
He was like,
all right,
let me have some.
But we always shoved him in the back with a lot with a login and stuff and his
back was like,
fuck,
I'm hurt.
It hurt.
Whatever.
He said like,
dude,
my back feels good.
Yeah,
well it starts smoking and he was like,
this is,
I feel better.
What part of the problem with back pain,
and this has been proven because it's stress related,
that a lot of times when people have like really stressful.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Back centrally.
There's a guy,
I think he's,
his name is John Sarno,
I think that's his name.
He's a,
he's a,
I'm a doctor from New York and he's like,
got this idea that I think his name is Sarano.
I should,
I should look this up,
but that it's psycho psychosomatic and Eddie Bravo actually found that his back
problems or psychosomatic because like you say,
if he's stressed,
he said that he was just so tense in the way he was thinking and he changed the
way he was thinking.
And when he changed the way he's thinking,
literally his back problems went away.
There's an old fable in the,
in the,
in the old testament that somebody,
some guy was trying to help a king.
He couldn't get a shoe off or something and you're like,
armor on.
If a shirt when he couldn't get it off and the king had to like calm him down or
they're the Jew had a calmness kicking down.
And then once that happened,
then his swelling went down in his foot and he was able to get the shoe off.
Huh?
Yeah,
you fucked that funny thing.
I fucked it up.
Good man.
Fucked it up.
Good.
These,
it's not your fault.
These face you answer.
Oh,
that's clearly the way to do it.
But now how,
just missing an angel.
That's good,
right there is good.
Can you tighten it up right there?
So,
uh,
that Jewish horror movie,
like I said,
it's a big box.
Yeah.
Well it's,
I think it's called the possession or so.
Yeah,
that's,
I just came out.
Yeah,
it was wicked stupid.
totally.
Unbelievable.
Completely retarded.
You like drag me to hell.
I was like this love,
love that child.
And a lot of ways,
I don't know if you've recognized that that time we were in San Jose and,
and we're all gonna go see a movie because it's so boring there and it's like
two blocks.
It's okay.
Yup.
That's it.
We're all going to the movie.
And you wouldn't,
Tom was like,
let's,
cause he'd drag me to hell and I was like,
barf.
Let's
go see up.
And you guys are like,
bar.
I put all my,
can I drag me to hell?
It was so much better than me and Brian.
I'm like a 14 year old.
Me and Brian cried it up.
Balling.
Aw,
that's so sweet.
Yeah.
I don't like getting depressed at the movies and updated,
depressed me when the old guy was in the house by himself.
I'm like,
I don't not want to watch this.
That's gross.
Watching someone right away that first 15 minutes into that you're like,
that's just a beautiful short him with the wife are coming up and then it's
depressing.
It's fuck.
Yeah,
so like with stuff touches me like that.
You don't like it.
I used to and I gave up.
I gave,
I gave up on that feeling like I don't need that.
I'm,
I'm trying to manage as much positive thinking in my life as possible.
The last thing I want to do is watch a movie about some guy is fucking shooting
heroin and falling apart and you know someone had accidentally hit someone with
a car because they're dry.
I don't want to see that.
I don't want to see it and I'm carrying,
I know need to see reality when I go to the fucking movies.
I want the hulk.
Really?
I would see me.
Yeah,
I would see it's been back and forth.
What's that?
Not even a back and forth.
A fuck about some depressing.
Yeah.
I'm not going to the movies.
You get depressed.
I don't have time,
man.
I'm thinking,
well,
I've got a lot of different interests,
you know,
and I'm into like,
I'm really into a lot of different things that I don't get to do a lot like play
pool.
The last thing was do is take some time with them playing pool.
You can feel to watch some movie or they want to make me cry like a bitch about
some shit.
That didn't even really happen.
I'm crying about some fake shit.
Suppose to,
you've got to Ali g movies and stuff like that for sure.
Yeah.
No,
no.
I love comedies.
Don't get me wrong.
Yeah.
I wanted to go see the new Will Ferrell Zach Galifianakis movie,
but it was sold out like a motherfucker.
Really?
Yeah.
We were 20 minutes before too.
I was like,
Oh shit.
I got crazy.
I thought I could go see that movie.
That movie is going to be like number one.
Apparently it's fucking when the come out and various just came out,
but I had a bunch of people say that when it went sides.
It's just so ridiculous.
It's like from the moment it starts,
he goes,
it's so fucking crazy.
Giggle fest because they're both so stupid.
Funny.
Like will Ferrell.
I've seen him in movies like the,
he's got like scenes in anchorman that is so preposterous.
But when the girl was starting to become famous and he was upset.
Yeah,
I mean it's like he's so,
it's so ridiculous and it's like,
all right.
It's funny.
Every movie that he's in it.
I've never seen a bad will Ferrell movie.
I've never seen a will Ferrell movie.
They didn't make me laugh.
Talladega nights is one of my all time favorite comedy.
That's how black girl rape the welfare because he loses it and then starts
talking Philip Seymour Hoffman or that whatever the guy's name is Leslie Bibb.
Yeah,
you're fucking other guys.
Like those are my kids now.
She was fighting with respect ex girlfriend in zookeeper.
Oh really?
Yeah,
she was the girl that I was trying to get from Kevin James.
she's really nice.
She's super cool as far as like,
you know,
you think about like hanging with actors that act as,
it'd be like real actory ish.
Leslie Bibb is cool as fuck and she's totally like an old guy.
Do we,
we were on the way to,
she's really funny and she's nice.
She's nice to everybody.
She's nice to the PAS.
She's nice to the makeup lady.
She's in this nice,
she's just nice,
but she's fucking really hilarious.
I don't know how much she would ever want anybody to know of this conversation,
so,
well,
I won't tell you any fault,
but she was cracking jokes about something and I was like,
I can't believe this is the chick from Talladega nights.
Yeah.
It was really funny.
She's really fun.
It's the burn money has been,
I've been get called another server about Sullivan and son a few times.
Sullivan and son was that stupid show?
It's on TBS.
Oh yeah.
TBS has like a lot of comedies now.
Right.
That's a recent thing,
right?
Is that where it Louis?
No,
he's at Fx,
but his,
his antibiotic.
But uh,
anyway,
I called it at some point,
you know,
you to hold on three times for like one same show.
It's like,
thank you.
Callie said something about me.
Yeah.
And he was like,
I'd so much rather hang out with a comic than an actor.
Oh yeah.
Even if it's just one line,
just I'd rather be,
normally I say that,
but then I'm like saying like this Leslie Bibb check.
Even though she's a,
she's not a comic,
she has a comic.
She might as well be a calm and that's an annoying comics too.
I wouldn't want to hang out with a course.
I'll tell it.
Look,
a lot of people that are actors,
the in comedy like Leslie Bibb could easily have been a standout,
you know?
Cool.
Yeah.
The same thing that,
you know,
Chelsea handler can pull off.
Leslie Bibb can pull that off to,
you know,
I mean,
I think she's a hand and say some shit,
but I've always thought she was hardcore.
She's funny.
It's not true.
Is the only girl that was talking about being a whore that is really a whore.
She was just like,
she ain't faking it.
She's always been nice to me.
I've always seen her.
I've never heard anybody say she's an asshole.
You know,
I don't,
you know,
I don't know what it's like on her set or anything like that.
But she's,
she was,
so,
she used to come into the store and like,
like Jeff Scott used to get mad about it sometimes,
but it was like a review for a book.
I wrote a blurb for that.
Yeah.
But she would come and sit in their car,
drink from a flask that go in and open the show and then take off of the night.
She was good.
I remember watching her and then the back of the room going,
wow,
this chick is fucking,
she's hard core.
She's a liquid jet hardcore.
Like she was really living it and she's really good.
I'm not,
am I pretending I'm a whore for the sake of a joke?
She's funny.
She's so,
yeah.
I,
I think,
you know,
it's a,
it's a way harder road for a chick to make it as a comedian and even talking
about anything than it is for a dude because the dude can get away with having
an opinion about things,
you know,
checks it's harder to,
or they just don't try.
Yeah.
Um,
well it's also like you'll listen to a guy on the stage with a conservative
point of view for a little bit.
You know what I mean?
You'll listen for a little bit if the guy is a respectable person.
Even Christopher Hitchens was like pretty,
pretty conservative when it came to a lot of a lot of military issues.
Oh yeah.
You know,
and these are obviously very liberal atheist at the same time,
but if you had a woman that was on stage,
so it was trying to get you to laugh and had opinion,
so completely polar opposite of your opinions as well,
you wouldn't be wanting to hear it.
She couldn't be talking about psychedelics and it's hard.
It's hard to do for them.
But like political opinions are fucking social opinions.
Shut your mouth woman I think
get to choose.
That's how guys think.
And I think it's way harder for a check to have a political point of view on of
them become like really like snappy,
like a good dog yelled at too much in the act.
Yeah,
they definitely get pushed into big characters more.
It's a been character acts.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I agree with just like Roseanne did,
just like Phyllis Diller did,
just like all these people did.
It really hasn't stopped.
But Sam was a monster.
Yeah.
You remember when I'm Roseanne first came out,
man,
I remember she was the first sheet too annoying for me at first that I ever
really kill.
It's really first chicken saw workout.
Really kill.
Oh No.
I don't think I ever saw her alive.
I might've saw her once at the store live and I can't remember,
but I've seen her specials,
you know,
senior specialist a bunch of times and I've tweeted back at her think she
admonished me for making a potty joke.
Oh really?
Like a mommy.
Is it as a joke?
I don't think so.
I think she was telling me to concentrate more and important issues.
Oh really?
She was one of the first women that get her say she goes,
well,
the my way,
that's Roseanne Barr Bitch.
But I recognize you're fired every show on her.
She had,
yeah.
Yeah.
You're all fired one at a time.
That's a weird thing that happens to people when they become like the star of
the five show.
Yeah,
you can.
You can't tell.
Roseanne would not.
After that second year,
it was like she was one of the biggest people in America.
She was huge and when she had a three way marriage,
her and Tom Arnold [inaudible],
Sandra Bernhardt or that other person.
Is that true?
Something like there was like a three way marriage.
Wow.
They're like,
we're marrying her being married.
Maritain nother person.
Oh Wow.
List.
Crazy drag.
How about we all get divorced,
live together.
Let's just make up my mind.
I need this.
Marriage is a sham.
We're bringing another person in here and this is get divorced and hang out
together.
Can we do that three way marriage?
Why don't have a 10 way marriage?
You'd dump.
Fuck that will when you break up,
you can't have any money.
How about that?
You don't get any of it.
All of it goes to other people.
They can't live off.
Let you make.
Yeah,
you can't.
Could you imagine if you got divorced from nine people and you had to pay them
all?
Me,
me,
me.
Like when you go to Tijuana and those little chiclets kids come up to you and
they'll be like that.
I got it.
The alimony all the time.
Yeah,
I mean you've got to,
you've got to think of how stupid it is.
Like I was having a conversation with somebody about a,
the Oj Simpson case the other day it came up and what they were talking about,
people like getting like super crazy because they have to pay so much in divorce
and we broke it down.
I go,
could you imagine if you had explained that to somebody that if they didn't
understand the system,
he's like,
yeah,
well what happens is you sign this paper and then when you're not together
anymore,
even if they're fucking other people,
you have to keep sending them money from a long time,
for years and years and years and they,
for whatever reason,
never have to get their shit together.
They never have to know.
And everyone's like,
get you what you have to do.
You have to support them.
Why crazy?
You know,
I have a friend,
wait,
was hold on.
Ife,
whose wife?
If she got married to the man that she loves,
she would lose all of her money so she won't marry him.
So this guy's like a bum and they lived together and this guy has to pay them
astronomical sums every month.
And the hill like get a credit order or,
or a,
um,
a court order to a,
to prove that she's living with a man and the guy would just move out for two
weeks.
The inspector comes and then he moves back in.
Here's the thing,
I understand that if you gave up your life and your career to raise a child for
someone else,
oh no,
no,
no.
He has no kids.
If you just marry someone in what world of equality do you think because you
guys decide to break up,
that one person should pay the other person.
What?
Equality World.
It's what if you get married for more than 12 years.
If then you're under five years in California.
No,
no,
no.
That's what I'm saying.
If you're married for more than 12 years and you,
uh,
you get divorced,
you grow apart a them,
you have to pay them forever
because you grew up in separate ways.
I mean,
that is one of the girl is not outraged by that.
It's a fucking cunt.
Every one of you,
whenever you want to quality,
just know that that's a rule set and go fuck yourself.
There's no way that's just still be around.
I got to wear that for a second.
I got two words to you right now.
Tom Arnold.
Yeah,
that's hard.
That's our backyard.
That's right.
Guys have run that hustle and Brittany Spears,
dude,
he's fat and he drives a Ferrari.
And every guy,
every guy who was excited about that,
like black people were excited about Oj getting off.
Well,
we knew this is ridiculous,
but finally one for us that you just went deep,
but 10 son.
It's a ridiculous law.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's craziness.
It's crazy that you could be separated by years and years and years.
And even the same amount of time that you were actually together.
I'll give you a year or together for 12 years and separated for 12 years.
No,
no.
In perpetuity.
You kind of keep paying.
We got married where?
18 now I'm 30 and cheat and have to pay forever.
Right?
A man,
she can't find a man who loves her enough to take her away from us.
They're tarnished goods because they've already been married for the lawn.
That who would want them?
Well,
it's not.
What the fuck is that?
It's not even that.
It's that like she can't trust him.
What?
I'm going to just trust you.
I'm going to marry you and you're going to stick around.
If I lose you,
I lose all this money.
I mean,
she gets a
substantial amount of money every year.
Hey,
what the fuck are you talking about?
How much it costs?
How much does she get?
Oh,
nothing.
Just about a million dollars here.
Remember that Chris rock bit.
It's okay to give him half of your money when you have $2 million.
Try when you are 30,000 yeah.
Can I get about 15,000 even when you have $2 million,
it's like it hurts your soul idea,
but it's so courageous.
Easy that if you write something down on paper another,
you have to keep paying them.
Like why can't you live your life like that seems to be kind of strange.
You're requiring,
yeah.
What kind of fucking weird enabling system do we have here?
You're not responsible for yourself.
I'm not going to say they were changing to be adults.
That's what we're trying to be.
I believe you said that.
He said,
I thought myself,
I try to grow as a human.
I try to grow as a human,
but that's what you're trying to be.
Fucking people unable to take care of themselves in any way.
It's ridiculous.
It's ridic.
Well,
the whole idea is we get injured in an accident.
Women want to be protected when they're raising children and to be legal.
Like some guys are douchebags and they don't want to pay for their kids and they
wouldn't want to pay alimony or child support.
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying in cases,
especially with there's no children.
It seems a little weird that you can be separated from someone for,
in my friend's case,
10 flop king.
He's paying a substantial,
let me say it again.
That's substantial amount of money.
My friend is a real,
a real worker.
He works.
He just,
you know,
he's got his own business.
He's like,
I mean this motherfucker puts in some hours.
Alright,
I'm telling too much.
He's also a wizard who lives in a cave and he drives a spaceship.
It's a fucking,
it's just a sad world when you see people destroyed by weird in an unequal legal
system quite what the fuck is.
That doesn't make any sense to fit that kind of behavior.
It just so crazy to think that someone who you don't want in your life anymore,
it's still your financial responsibilities about the last two years was a living
hell.
Yeah.
That doesn't buy you anything.
Any discounts.
Yeah.
And this is,
you know,
we're talking about grown adults.
I mean,
you would assume that you've done something with your life that's trade worthy
haylage or the way the sleep next to each other for the last two years.
It doesn't matter.
You weren't,
yeah,
no bed together.
You know,
you might fucking,
she might insult you and you're at dinner.
I mean,
make up your own horrifying scenario that it could have been.
And imagine you have to pay on a person a million a year.
It's craziness.
20 bucks.
That's what you got.
What you were able to get out of prison.
The whole idea behind paying people money is fucking crazy.
But the whole idea behind charity is beautiful.
And when people don't get charity from people,
they want to get it from them.
You'll get it.
To me.
And it's a fucking horrible aspect of human nature that people want something
that they don't deserve,
but we all want it after we get it for a while.
We all want it.
Yeah.
You all want to slip and fall and sue after you get put in anything.
Even when you start getting spots at the comedy store.
Think now I get them.
I deserved them.
Yes.
Yeah.
You gets like this.
It's hard to maintain humility and appreciation.
Those are two very hard aspects of the human,
the human experience to really maintain.
And hang on to.
Yeah.
It's hard to be a nice person.
I was talking to this guy in Toronto,
this new comic he was doing me.
If it's off then something like web thing.
Powerful Toronto coming soon.
Massey Hall and you're going to be able to,
I'm also doing shows in Toronto,
but just for laughs to that,
that's,
I would probably be by there to hang out at very least.
At the very least.
So legally we can't say that.
Archerfield we'll be performing.
Yeah,
but you know how the sales would that show?
Oh yeah.
You're going to get all sold out.
Yeah.
It's almost sold out and they all,
we,
you know it's,
it's,
look,
Massey Hall is one of the fucking coolest places on earth.
Have you ever done it?
No Dude.
Like the fucking Beatles did it and shit.
It's like one of those places.
Oh,
it's insanity.
I'm scared.
Just thinking about it now I'm getting tuned up.
Yeah.
I'm so far enough for that show.
I'm fine enough for this weekend too.
I'm doing the Lobero theater in Santa Monica or Santa Barbara Rather.
Santa Barbara is a pretty fucking Barbara.
You ever go there?
Uh,
I just went camping near like halfway there too.
I'm telling you.
It's so nice to go camping.
You gotta do it.
Silly Bitch.
It's so much fun.
You see fucking animals?
We've got tagged by a skunk.
Yeah,
that's not good.
It was that like it's good.
It was sell fine.
It's conscious or not good to only one.
I had to walk through it with camping.
That's serial killer bait.
Then you went out into the wild ass wild.
The wild that you can get to your car in La is not real wild trailer bait or do
you want to go?
Got to go to Montana sign.
I'm going to go somewhere legit.
That's too involved.
We want to take mushrooms and drive somewhere.
Hey,
but I'm telling you that you're just asking to get eaten.
That's what you can do it.
If you go into one of those creepy,
creepy semi wooded areas and this family's there.
Griffith Park is a good place to find it from afar cause he got flights to get a
blowjob.
Griffith Park is different.
It's a good place to find a pit that that's what may we all cook,
the homeless guy.
That's,
that's the kind of place where you find some shit like that.
You know?
It's not like the real woods.
It's not like Colorado.
I like walking through the trails in the Rockies.
It's the closest place where I can get away from everyone.
Yeah,
and that's so much fun sometimes to get away from everybody.
If I had a houseboat,
I'd take it out.
Sometimes Phuc yen is,
but the problem is the places you're going,
anybody you run into,
you're going to have to kill.
You have to kill it.
A hand to hand fight.
He's going to be trying to take your life,
get a call back on those holds school 10th planet.
When my dad taught me about the Israeli army.
Yeah.
What am I remember kicking the balls to do it?
I'm so bummed out that you hurt your knees.
I really loved the fact that you got into Jiu Jitsu and yesterday he got
proficient at it for a while.
I remember seeing you get a few taps and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Already happened.
People,
anyone who's thinking of doing it,
it's so invigorating to get that.
It's like I could sort of the same but way better than what you come back again.
Well,
why don't you just lift a little weights for a couple of months,
build your,
your body after a little bit.
I uh,
I'm about to go back now.
I had a pretty significant back injury where I,
I popped it,
I miss it sometimes and I tried to,
I tried to keep rolling.
I tried to like,
like just rolled light and just use technique and I heard it really bad to the
point where I was getting numbness in my hands.
It was intense.
Yeah,
it was intense.
And then I came back for a little and I got my black belt and then I heard it
again and I was like,
mother fucker.
I said,
all right,
I can't just rest this.
I gotta make this thing stronger.
I should say that because I don't think I got interested in Jujitsu.
I think I got injured from kettlebells.
Soil stayed.
Anyone doesn't be careful and don't go,
don't bend past a certain level.
Well,
honestly,
I think before you even do kettle bells for you because you had been kind of
sedentary,
I think it would've been nice a little bit and try and try and be a friend,
brother.
You know what?
I love it.
You were growing up.
You could have a started off with perhaps like some body weight squats and some
pushups and likely he'll conservative sort of a buildup phase because what
happened to you has happened to people before your break?
Yeah,
you can.
You can fuck yourself up.
Kevin Pereira had the exact same problem and told me at some point he's like,
but honestly,
dude,
you're 36 or 37 it can't.
You can't.
That's,
that's what's going to happen.
That's calendar.
The guy that's right before he lifted his shirt and then pounded himself,
Fox News,
messenger of doom.
It comes to,
if you're,
if you're talking about great,
your body was,
he would have went that way with,
he just really loves being talent,
but now he is writing a lot of ways.
I mean,
when you're older for short,
that shit breaks more.
Especially if you think of the fact that you're 36 and I've topic being 36,
you're also like,
you know,
you haven't,
you,
you haven't been in the best of shape.
So you,
you were,
you got to that age and on top of it you were like,
like not eating well,
eating healthy.
I'm going to whole foods.
I want to.
Once high stoned drove in there,
I was like,
let me say it and our salad bar was so fucking good and full of different
flavors.
Then I'm like,
I can do this.
It truly makes a different eat healthy and people don't understand.
They don't,
you don't know what you're depriving yourself out of.
It doesn't mean,
it doesn't mean that it doesn't mean to be a vegetarian either.
It means,
um,
it means getting a lot of nutrition.
I,
it's weird though.
I just did it because it tasted okay.
But after like a month,
like a solid month of doing it,
like all the time,
um,
like eight,
nine of those a day,
not a day a week.
Um,
after that I could feel better.
Like I would feel like more in court.
More energy and like better.
Yeah,
of course.
It's like when you quit smoking too.
I'm sure it must've been the same sort of a thing.
Get to shine.
I would like to say that.
Relax.
No like to say that,
but it just had a real pull back.
Huh?
It's always pulled you a little bit back.
I'm,
I'm better off it now.
The Pot helps cause I get that feeling of smoking something which were relieved
that that little feeling so,
but for the longest time after that it always pulled you right.
Oh,
you're just always wanting to get on.
And then when you see,
let me see people smoking like I want,
I want to be part of this.
I want to be with you guys smoking right now.
It's so weird how it's so different for different people.
Like some people quit smoking and then they feel like they have so much energy
and they feel so much better and they feel like they've got out from under a
rock.
Like something was weighing them down and then some people will quit and they
never quite get over that pole and just keep trying.
I had to accept like you don't have,
I said,
hey though you're powerless over the drug.
Like every time I'm like,
I'll just have like one or two a day for a week.
It's like,
no,
I don't have power over this.
It'll be back in half a pack to a pack every day.
Those Gary,
it's so scary that they made it that way.
Oh yeah.
The addictive stuff isn't what isn't.
What gets you the good feeling.
He Mitt Romney.
Can we talk about this?
Hey Barack Obama,
can we talk about this poison that kills a half a million people a year here.
It kills like something nutty,
like 5 million worldwide die every year from cigarettes and like,
wow.
Could you imagine if you came out with some new shit like skin cream there was
killed,
killed five people were how long before they had pulled that shit off the
market?
That's a fucking plague.
That's a play to new aids.
It's,
well,
it's an old days.
It would be so many more people if we didn't have it though.
Thank God for cigarettes and hey,
it's thinking about cigarettes and aids.
It only helps us out getting the freeway still.
The four or five is jammed with all these people.
Drop it off.
I'm cigarettes.
There's something sad to me about an old lady smoking cigarettes and I know
that's stupid and hypocritical,
but I want to feel like an old lady should have someone in her life who loves
her enough to get it to quit smoking.
It's like you did it.
You did it.
You made it again.
Bays.
He got through.
It was like she survived the hunger games.
There's some women that have that,
that brassy.
They know you don't want to fuck them.
It's done,
so it's cold.
You're okay with it.
And so like there,
there are different thing.
It's not like a woman.
They become like this really old thing and we can,
wow.
I'll tell you what,
when you were my age,
I've been undesirable for 28 years.
They get accustomed to it.
Yeah.
That must be so sad though,
for a check because really beautiful chicks are super powerful.
They have super powers.
You know,
they go into a room and everybody loves them despite their absolute,
they talk,
I said this on Twitter,
but I realized it recently.
It's like the only difference in someone who would look at as a crazy person at
someone who looks at it as like cute or quirky.
His fuckability.
That's true.
That's the only difference.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You look back and think about some of the girls that you dated and men too,
nutty flavor.
Flave what's the same behavior then that he has now,
but because he was younger and more vibrant.
Oh yeah.
They're like,
oh,
that's okay.
I guess just a little weird.
Yeah.
If you want to fuck them,
they become ways or are hanging out with when they can justify their behavior.
Insane or or terrible.
Well,
don't you think like a certain point in your life when you meet a person,
they're just your sex dispenser part of it.
You masturbate with them.
Yeah.
You masturbate with them like you've,
there's,
there's people that you have legitimate relationships with.
There's some people that you just in never click with also sort of boat on any
level.
They're both.
So I apologize for girlfriends in my mind that had been like rude to wait staff
and I later I'm like,
oh,
she likes service done.
Right.
That's all.
But it's like in your head you'd like come on is an asshole and you're ignoring
it.
People get,
they grow up with that shit.
That's a problem.
We're so adaptable.
You know,
if you look at all the different,
to sort of like crazy cultures and what they can don't,
don't condone all over the world.
And if you think about how similar human beings are genetically,
like all
the,
where the variation is so small,
but yet the behavior patterns are so radically different between like,
you know,
like what's going on right now in Bahrain,
what's going on right now?
You know,
and it was amped up hills.
Yeah.
I mean the same error on earth.
The apocalypse is going on in one place and another place,
you know,
you're walking down the street in Bel Air and as manicured lawns and everyone's
friendly and it smells great flowers everywhere or the chirping,
you getting your convertible,
you drive down to Starbucks,
he sit there with your feet up on a chair,
every war.
Everything's so great.
I remember it was you,
me Diaz.
Um,
and I think,
I think doc,
it might've been with us too.
It was one of the days after nine 11 before the planes started flying again and
we were all sitting around like outside of a Starbucks or one of those coffee
beans or something like that.
And we were sitting around just this talking about how beautiful it was.
Like how could they be a war right now we're,
we're,
we're going where we're sitting right here in southern California.
That's so far removed.
It was so beautiful.
There was no planes,
there was no planes flying around because it was nine 11.
So like you never got to hear anything fly overhead.
And it was like way quieter.
It was almost like we went back in time for a couple of days.
It was weird,
man.
You don't realize how often you hear fucking planes,
especially what you live.
You're anywhere near the airport.
Those fucking things here at all the time.
Gorgeous.
Yeah.
That's why whenever you shoot something and it's the sound guy has to be like
playing and you're like,
oh,
I didn't know all the time.
I'm a wizard of catching that shit.
Sounds like I was going to ruin the shot.
Yeah.
I'll stop people from doing things on fear factor.
Like hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
We got playing.
We got to play you to play.
Um,
but yeah,
that we were sitting around and I remember we were thinking like how could that
be a war going on somewhere?
How could there be a place of such complete disarray that planes are flying into
buildings and thousands of people are dying when you and me and d as it just
sitting here high as fuck,
drinking coffee and just kicking back,
looking at the sun,
you know,
and it's perfect weather.
We're,
we're too connected with the whole world.
Man,
you know,
sometimes it's like there should be just a village.
Like we're just here now.
We shouldn't worry about what's happening over there or a different planet or
different like whatever.
It's like it's not our star system.
We have to having a good time.
The problem is then other people form gangs and they take over just like that
mind movie.
It's almost like,
you know when people say this,
I'm like Americans,
uh,
those troops are fighting for our freedom.
Yeah,
they're not but not fighting for our freedom.
But they are.
But they are because someone always throughout history,
he's become the baddest motherfuckers on the planet.
Someone,
whether it was the Greeks or the Romans or the United States of America,
somebody had to dictate what the fuck happens.
The,
there's no one ever done it as well as the US has done it.
But we've always had to do it and the guy in charge.
And so the argument is,
look,
if anybody's going to do it,
it should be us.
Cause let me tell you something.
As far as the rest of the country.
The rest of the world goes.
We're about as nice as you can get as far as like how we treat our own.
This is about as nice as we can get,
know this kind of power,
but then you think like we're the only ones you ever dropped the bomb or the
only ones that ever did that.
We don't trust anybody else with it.
When the only only person that has a loss on that and we have to,
we're open to,
what's fucked up is that we dropped two bombs.
We dropped the bomb.
They were like,
I quit.
I can hear.
It was like those hacking up comedy clubs.
Y'All ready for Ari Shaffir kid here.
You here's my new jail.
Y'All good?
He foe.
We shift jokes.
I want you to think of this.
Okay,
I'll just do it now.
I don't care.
I'm going to be like,
hey,
you guys like impressions and you don't have right claps.
I'm going to go.
No you don't.
Why don't you clap at that?
You know you don't want them.
You don't like them.
It's a good joke.
You're telling people what they like.
I love it.
Does it like some fresh air?
It's no big deal.
Everyone claps.
I'm like,
all right,
are you like different things?
And then the people,
there's a man named rich little,
he made his whole career at a making impressions in the pocket.
1830 Danny Gans,
Danny Gans before he died of pills,
by the way.
No stress or having to do impressions all day long,
every day that ate away at his inside of pills,
whatever it was,
wasn't taking the pills for cause it was an awesome mood all the time.
Oh,
it likes it.
And like you said,
or you can get addicted to those terrible places to do a great bit about debt
against
[inaudible] in Vegas.
As soon as he steps on the bus to leave Vegas when it leaves city limits,
like den against taking the bus away from Vick,
Susan,
everybody goes back there and spits in his face.
Isn't that funny?
He'll gans do you have to be like people I have to qualify his success.
Well,
it's Vegas.
Yeah.
Well,
Rita Rudner too.
She was one that was kind of struggling a little bit on the road.
Like there's,
there was a bunch of,
Margaret Smith was in that category of women is like really funny women standup
comics,
but at a certain point in time that you stopped hearing about them.
You know Margaret Smith was hilarious.
We went to Vegas.
She was like in the Kinison era.
She didn't,
but Rudner was from her era and Rudner herbs carved out like a huge career for
herself in Vegas.
Every time I'm there I see posters and billboards and shit.
She's always liked weird dealer act in Vegas.
Yeah.
What's also people going to look forward to seeing her again for something
that's like the comedy scene is shit in Vegas because there's so many great
shows at all times.
Why don't we go see a local guy?
We're sinking legends.
There's 10 legends playing at any point right here.
What am I going to see?
Yeah,
you can go see bill Cosby and if you're local to can get two for ones are comps.
Yeah.
You can see bill cosmetics and Joe Rogan.
You could sit back and Seinfeld,
whoever you love.
I mean Damn you just put me in with Seinfeld and bill Cosby.
Holla.
Yeah,
that's right.
Your knuckles.
You can see a lot of good comedy,
man.
We were so looking forward to doing that show.
I took off weeks for that.
So sad.
And we wound up in it and we wound up bringing it to the,
uh,
the ice house.
Can I make an announcement?
That was yeah.
Fucking image.
My CD is coming up
called revenge for the Holocaust.
Whoa.
I like it.
Thank you.
That's a good name.
That's beautiful.
Is it going to be on Itunes as well?
Itunes,
September 25th.
Uh,
it goes on sale
probably this weekend,
dude.
We're going over today below that fucking thing out.
It goes on sale today.
Like online,
iTunes,
when Wednesday out,
it's,
it's up to,
it'll,
it's going up to iTunes today will probably be up there Friday.
Oh cal from presale.
But September the 25th is the official first,
um,
for sale.
But here's what I'm doing,
but you can buy a presale.
What does that mean?
Start buying it and then it comes out in the 25th.
Just give me,
you know,
give it to you.
Give it to me.
Yeah.
But you were really happy with this one too.
I'm really happy with it.
I'm really excited and the cover my friend of the cover and I fucking love it.
Oh,
that's dope.
Um,
I like that.
Oh,
that has a light down please.
An evil juice spider.
Yeah.
Going after Hitler.
Spy Das.
Beautiful Dude.
Um,
but yeah,
but if you've got to my website,
I'm giving away four tracks.
That might be one of my favorite CD covers a,
it's pretty sweet,
right?
I was really thinking if I was a just an a an a nine comedian,
like a kid who really was in a comedy,
like I was at one point in time,
if I ever found this in the CD aisle,
like at the record store,
but like,
oh fuck yeah,
I can already,
she fears new shit,
revenge for the Holocaust.
I would buy that.
Just out of general principles.
Yeah.
If I knew that that was a standup comic,
I had an uncle that used to do that.
My uncle Vinny and he would,
uh,
he was from the era of records,
but he would take it to the record store and he goes,
I would just be the album mark.
Yeah.
He'll buy a record just based on its album art.
And I've done that before too and made horrendous mistakes,
especially when it comes to like fantasy or swords and shit.
I like iron maiden.
I can get into some art schools,
the art to what they think is cool.
Is there artwork there are working same with grateful dead.
It's like the art work is way better than this leper iron.
Is that Monster Wright Edelman a bat out of hell.
Yeah,
they do that.
I've never seen this is what they do.
They have a few tours,
shirts for the year.
They will never be produced that art,
they're done selling that shirt forever.
After that they have it like a North American tour and it's done.
That doesn't make sense to me.
You're a new shirt and so now you have a 2010 shirts.
Someone else has the 2007 shirt.
You're all at fucking the same festival.
I get it.
But what if the 2007 shirt is awesome and I want to buy one,
you know,
and I want to be able to buy the old collectors items.
I feel like you should just keep selling them that too.
But I like something about like we were there and you had to be there to get,
you know,
and I don't like about it.
You artificially control the supply.
Like you decide.
There's only rule rural going to release 250 why if a thousand people bought
himself thousand,
he crazy.
Fuck White.
Creating a mad clan only get it live.
Like what about the people can say a little,
if a million people want to buy your crazy fucking hat,
you're only going to sell 10 hats.
This is a limited edition run of 10 hats.
All the hats.
Okay.
Anyway,
I'm giving away four tracks for free.
If you go to my website [inaudible] dot com or or you should have your.com just
go there.
I'm,
I'm honestly really happy with it and I think if you listen to it,
you'll be a fan.
So [inaudible] why are you pumping your own shit up like that?
I do like it.
I like it.
Let me do it.
Fuck it helped me out.
Right.
You should fear,
I've known ours you for your fraud a long fucking time.
And I took Ari on the road of me when Ari was like in that stage of standup
comedy,
like you were like a couple of years and how many years in what you do and we
five,
five years,
I was like,
you were there and not you.
You could have some great nights and you could say,
but I've watched you rookie mistakes.
Yeah,
but you made some fucking great moments to the rookie mistakes are fine.
It's the,
the,
the real problem is the lack of the great moments in with the rookie mistakes.
He would have like hilarious bits and then you would clump one in there.
But that's everybody.
Does that look like you just were trying to find like,
you know,
find the foot footer.
It'd be too out there or too little,
whatever it is.
We feel yourself pushing a bit too hard.
But I've watched you transform into like a real legit headliner.
It's been fucking cool,
especially over the last couple of years because of uh,
doing a lot of podcasts and you know,
do it a lot of internet related stuff.
You got,
you know,
especially the,
you got really famous for the,
the uh,
the racist stuff [inaudible] stuff and then you know from that to like,
you know,
senior stand up,
like,
and you know,
you put out no one ever came to see me from that though.
Yeah.
But here or there,
but it's all podcast stuff now,
right?
It's all people coming to see you from the podcast and then remembering that
other stuff.
I also liked you when you did that stuff and it's people that have come to Vegas
when we performed the form before too,
that help.
That's the best one.
You and I have done thousands of shows.
Have you stop and think about all the fucking shows that we did and all the
different places and all the different Friday nights where we did two shows and
Saturday nights where we did two shows.
Then we did a show on Sunday and sometimes we did Thursday too.
Yeah,
yeah.
We did all last started at four day weeks.
Yeah,
I've watched it got too crazy.
That's like not a comfortable way to do the road.
When you're doing the road,
it's four to five days out at a time.
It's like,
yeah,
me fucking home this home for one day.
You kind of manage like the uncomfort with the the like what are you getting out
of it?
I've had to do that,
but then the problem is this.
It's like I told you I have like three weeks and I'll have like a week off.
Then have another three weeks.
I'm like,
I need that week off.
Right,
but the DC improv calls and you're like,
fuck,
I gotta go there.
The crazy thing is even the week off,
it's like,
why not go on stage?
At the comedy store and do it there.
We have the greatest job in the history of the world and it's not an easy job.
It's hard to figure out how to get really good at it.
But once you get good at it then it becomes easy.
And it's the most rewarding shit of all time.
We did the ice house this past weekend.
We did a two shows there and it was fucking sensational.
Fucking sensational.
Friday and Saturday.
Friday is always like a little weird because people are tired and we do a late
show is like a 10 30 show on Friday.
So it doesn't really start til 11.
And people have been like working all day and then they start drinking.
It's hard to like,
it's Saturday was off the fucking chain.
Saturday was amazing,
you know,
and uh,
Bob Fisher came on stage and brought up a bottle of champagne and you know,
it's so cool.
He's a,
that's a long way
from having to hide the fact that you were drinking on stage at the Tempe
Improv,
put it in a flask and say it's apple juice.
And the most ridiculous showing him bring up stage to you.
Isn't that the Missouri
[inaudible] Shit like literally of all time.
He's had some great shows.
If I was some great times,
we,
we literally did that.
We,
we
brought a flask on stage if it wouldn't let us drink.
They said it was a state law or something,
a law because Christians on the place,
they beat up a lot.
It's so stupid.
And I,
and I had to say
the owner,
I said,
listen man,
I go,
this place is filled with people that want to see us get crazy.
Okay.
We want to get crazy,
but it's true.
Let's,
I want to do a couple shots.
Yeah.
Like come on man.
I'm here to start a party.
I'm here to do a standup comedy show.
I like to have fun.
Let's have some fun.
I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
I'm not sure.
Child,
they wouldn't serve it to the green room.
And then Red van got a great idea and Rogan's and funded it because yeah.
Whiskey in a flask and I up on a bunch of bottles,
put in that back corner,
got fucked up and then we just kept saying,
can I have some more Coca Cola?
Yeah,
we just got pull lasted on Coca Cola.
They couldn't figure out what was going on.
Tipping the wage to have 100 bucks for Coca Cola,
but then the somebody ratted you out.
It was one of the waitresses was a,
she was a familiar,
oh my god,
there's alcohol on stage.
Remember what he said to me on the stage.
Remember when we got there?
Every tick we got there and we were in the parking lot,
joint disease already and so I guess he likes things done at you.
Yeah,
we're in the parking lot a couple minutes early.
We're like,
let's smoke a joint.
Yeah,
and we'll go in.
yeah.
Start.
The show will be in a couple minutes to fit.
The music wasn't even on,
I call it like damn to talk to you.
I was like,
what?
Why?
He goes to fuck.
We had to delay the show for 30 minutes because of you.
People are standing in the rain and like,
what?
What is rain?
What's minutes?
What are you talking about?
He would just make shit up.
It was the first time ever talked back to a club owner.
He goes,
he goes,
well you're not going on this show.
And I'm like,
I have damn well going on this show.
This is your only reason I'm here.
I give a fuck about the money I'm going on this show.
You almost got that loud.
I didn't get that loud.
I said,
Dan,
I'm going on and then I got super worried or
you've got like really hard but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm going on and then you can't,
I go to,
you're going on stop it.
That helps a lot.
Well at a certain point in time what we would do the way we did when the
Improv's or like some of the most professionally run clubs in the country,
but at a certain point in time we would take over the room.
Me The other way.
Well we took over the room.
Well,
like a lot of clubs you go to,
like even when calen goes on the road,
Callen doesn't do it the same way we do it with Cowan does is he goes there and
they have an opening act in the Middle Act,
that day book and he just shows up.
He's the headliner.
That way he doesn't have to pay as much for,
you know,
those people's airfare and all the other shit that I paid for.
But for me I'm like,
what are you doing?
Like you can't,
you don't take over the room that way then then then you have to like deal with
on the show,
then you're just a part of an act and you're part of a comedy club experience
that's way more whole fucking night that way.
So we would,
we would do is say,
listen,
we're going to provide the opening ag where we're going to provide the Middle
Act and it's not up to them to say yes or no.
It's like I,
I've got a long,
long,
long reputation of bringing funny people on the road with me.
I always bring headliners on the road with me.
So you know it's going to be a top level act,
so don't worry about that.
And if it's a matter of whether or not,
you know,
you think my,
my,
my audience can't handle it.
Well that's not your,
it's not up to you to decide because you brought the melodic,
yeah,
I brought some people who you might be 20% of the audience 10% right.
So happy tried to get,
he tried to get crazy but I was looking just now he can't get crazy.
We bought the room.
We essentially have a contract.
Like you can't just break the contract because you decide that a guy is late.
Like that's crazy.
He's really working for me.
I'm a private contract.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I'm a subcontractor to this contract.
We don't make me fucking smack you bitch.
Sit the fuck down.
Crazy asshole.
He was just a dude who liked to party and he would come to work the next day
with a headache and he gets fucking grumpy.
His shit when I'm,
when I made a dude like that,
honestly,
I mean,
I'd love Danny Maher and I'm not talking about him in particular because I
really never had a problem with that.
He,
me,
he and I never had a problem.
We know he was upset at me once because I came into town to do a theater.
Uh,
and I didn't do his club,
but the only reason why I did is because it's radio station promoted it.
Like to me it was like this radio station had played,
um,
my Voodoo Panini song.
It became like the number one song in Phoenix.
Only a Phoenix.
Yeah.
So they wanted me to come in and do a show for them.
I couldn't say no.
Nobody.
It was like 1999.
It's like,
no,
I couldn't say no.
It's like nobody ever offered to put me in a theater before.
Like,
Holy Shit,
it's radio station's going to take it.
You like to,
no offense to the other club.
Sorry.
It's not,
I'm not against you.
Yeah.
Like,
come on,
offer for something,
Dude.
You know,
recognize.
But,
but when I,
when I see a dude who gets like snippy and snappy like that,
I get sad because I know that that's just a person who's chemical system is just
completely out of fucking watch act.
He's just unhealthy.
How,
how the fuck could be,
there's no way that guy is healthy.
They're kind of a mess.
Yeah.
He's,
you know,
his whole system,
it was always tired and you know,
when you see people and you know,
their shit's not flowing well,
you just really like,
you don't,
you see that now?
Like when you're eating healthy,
you see,
you feel how much different your body feels.
And of course we react the opposite way when you're at the opposite coming on
the road with you,
probably that,
ah,
the comedy store and maybe my upbringing were the,
probably the biggest influences on my,
on my stand up,
those three things.
Because seeing those big crowds and then being able to temper it with fucking
shitty eight person rooms at the store,
well,
something happened along the way,
uh,
within last few years where people started recognizing you and they knew to
expect you.
Whereas I used to bring you up and the real meatheads would
bring broken gap,
the real douchey dudes that I really got rid of almost all of them now,
but then a couple times just to hear a little,
a little by little,
a couple people like,
are you going to have tonight?
I was like,
yeah,
really.
You know me ahead of time.
Yeah,
and I would see it on the forums and shit.
I hope already comes with them.
Then somewhere along the line it'd be,
ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome our,
I should fear all excited for it.
Weird lately man,
the w the Diaz ones that I've been recording everywhere,
they're trying to top themselves because it's now it's become like some sort of
a crazy competition because in Denver they went fucking Berserk.
They went Berzerk Winnipeg in 2010 was the first time I saw that on a large
scale level because I don't know if you've ever played Winnipeg.
I never been back.
It was my favorite show of 2010 it was crazy blood man and that was the only
place I could do like that back then.
Like I said,
two or three level place and they went so crazy.
Well it's not,
but I could tell when I,
right when I walked on they like as you were saying,
introduction notes.
They were like they start clapping.
Yeah cause they know who it is.
I just say credits.
Yeah,
the I was whatever reason man.
My comedy took off and Co in Canada before it ever did in America.
Like I would,
I would do way better in theaters and Canada.
I remember we would do like Calgary,
we'd have to do two shows.
Well I did two shows recently had two shows at that fucking Jack Singer concert
hall and we did a show where they sold out like an extra,
I don't know how many seats,
but they had to bring them on stage.
So we had people on the stage witness,
but it was like there was the,
we,
they gave us the option of that or those people get refunded and they have to go
home.
I was like,
fuck,
I'm just going to be a cool story because these people had like babysitters and
shit.
I mean,
who knows what kind of music out behind us,
but then they couldn't do,
they couldn't do that.
It was at least 80 people.
Oh,
it was a lot of people.
They are just humongous.
We didn't need it all.
We don't need it all.
They were like,
give something to them and it was became fodder,
you know,
it became kind of funny.
Then.
You know,
you're standing next to someone who's in a chair.
It was just watching you.
Every time I've got a hump out,
you're in some old lady's face or like,
so sorry about this,
ma'am.
I've got to do this here.
You're looking at their drink on this delicious.
What is that?
That looks awesome.
[inaudible] halted.
Oh,
nice interruption yesterday.
Would you like that?
Not the interruption.
Doug loves movies and uh,
some guy in the front row was bringing out those purple,
the grape Twizzlers.
And I was like,
oh.
And he was like,
gave me the sign of like drama.
I like nodded and he throwing up to me.
It was awesome.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
it's was flung grape twizzler
people a solid saw a piece of candy.
Yeah,
it's good.
Good invention.
It doesn't taste anything like grape.
We were talking about this the other day because I did the podcast that we have.
Uh,
we've accepted a fake grape taste for grape soda,
grape gum disease,
anything like a real great,
but when you eat it and go,
oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
Like you just,
you,
you accept it as being a fake grape,
you know,
like Cherry Soda Sherry,
unless you're getting some like legit Deli Cherry soda,
Maris Shino Cherry Juice,
Cherry Cherries,
cherries.
So I was pretty fucking good though,
isn't it?
Cherry coke.
It's pretty rare.
And if you're really looking at a wreck,
your fucking immune system and you're eating like a pastrami sandwich with,
you know,
fucking thousand island dressing slot out the sides of it.
And you have a cherry coke.
Oh yeah.
Gimme gimme craziness.
I went and my sugar,
I love it too,
when they're like,
we don't have the Greenwich when we pour the juice in,
I was like,
yeah.
Oh,
are the juicy God.
He'd go that deep.
Yeah.
One time at a Denny's.
We're all eating there and I asked her for Terry like put the cherry juice and
she didn't know and she poured the thing out but it was all the peanuts had like
leaked over in their Sunday area,
the peanuts floating in it.
And I was ahead of like what is peanuts doing in here?
And then I realized what it was that she just poured the whole Sunday area thing
over to get the cherry juice out.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a little too much sugar free system son.
Now my system,
it's like
yeah it's so bad for you to drink that much sugar to eat that much sugar show.
And they like,
I keep reading shit about sugar,
how bad it is.
I've got to try to wean off it.
Why does it taste so God damn.
Cause when I haven't had it in a while cause I ate so much of it when I haven't
had in awhile I get low blood sugar cause I'm used to it now.
You know what dude?
You know what you can't fuck with Haagen daas chocolate ice cream ice cream.
It's delicious.
It's good if you want invest in a quality ice cream bar or chocolate bar.
Sometimes when you're like nothing,
let me just get Nestle's.
That's okay,
but let me go above and beyond.
You're like,
oh,
this is done better.
He would the hog and I wonder,
it's a dollar extra dark chocolate bar.
It's dark chocolate on the outside with chocolate on the inside.
Oh,
you ever go to a real hug and I was a place where they dip it in the chocolate.
Let it melt right on there for you.
Those are awesome.
Yeah,
and you don't know,
by the way,
none of you know what ice cream tastes like unless you smoke pot.
Yes,
it is.
Sunday.
Tastes like pitch.
You're living in a dream.
You are.
You're sucking a dick through a roll of toilet paper.
You're not feeling it.
You're not getting the,
the full experience.
There is no better.
Part of my depression then when I had was taking some medications,
let me have hyper phasia right.
Would never feel full and we're going to get stoned.
Oh my.
Not feel full and just for an hour,
just her up and cream.
Just more and more.
Did you hit the wall?
It was so.
I only had to tell myself you're done,
but what did you feel your like,
did you feel like exhausted from all the sugar?
No.
You would just get a little more weight down to don't eat for three.
I would eat til there's nothing left to eat.
Oh my God.
It was so good.
When you get high,
you can finish off anything.
Wow,
dude,
that seems like dangerous.
Oh yeah,
get so you can't get full to king.
Your stomach explode.
Can you eat too much?
They warn you.
I have to be like,
okay,
a plates of Spaghetti.
Probably.
That's enough.
Can you,
can it break?
I mean your stomach can break,
right?
Do those eater guys,
those probably Barf Barf.
You throw up.
I guess it's like drinking a gallon of milk.
You can't do it because your body would make you throw it up.
Is that true?
That's this rumor.
Really.
Well,
I guess there's not enough room.
Yeah.
And you would want to it,
but then imagine if you could drink down.
I'm,
they'll put your fucking stomach would look like.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
I Bet Joey Diaz could drink a gallon of milk we had and me and David Kelly's
talks that we had mark hatch was going to come in and try to see if it is,
is a big guy.
I'd be willing to let him know he's not going to do it.
You don't think he could do it?
He doesn't want to be,
he doesn't want you to human life.
He would not going to make fun of my,
he would do it.
Yeah,
but if he wanted to do it,
he could do and I think he couldn't.
You don't think you'd do it?
Nope.
So a physiological thing,
no one can do it.
It's like you can't eat a piece of white bread or two pieces of white bread.
If I'm looking at Tim Silvia,
like up giant dude.
I say,
no,
you don't think you could do,
I even say big Ben Big Ben Rothwell.
Yeah.
Really?
He couldn't drink it.
You're no Nelson.
Who's the guy with the boy?
Nelson.
Yeah.
You don't think he could do that?
Next time we see Roy Nelson,
let's try to ask him.
Well he'd be fighting.
I guess we can do it in the middle of that or later.
You can't say,
hey this is good fight.
Hey,
um,
can you picture to drown them out?
Just totally blow off the drive and I just,
you have an hour to the death against Shane carwash and either you're not
training anymore.
Can we interest you in filming you drinking if,
if,
if Nelson is out there,
please film that fight.
Listen man,
I have a podcast and a,
we were regularly number 40 on iTunes.
I'd be willing to actually put this on line.
If you would a drink a gallon of milk.
Do you think you can train your calendar?
I think you have to do it.
Film the whole thing and watch them start barfing wow.
Well I don't know man.
You and I should be the ones who talk about that actually because we were there
for the opie and Anthony.
Big Bird Challenge.
How much do you think that guy drank?
Cause he wasn't like the 70 shot double shot.
Just one double shot every,
every minute.
What's a double shot?
No,
what is the double shows like that I'm doing?
How many ounces?
I don't know.
We'd have to find out the exact amounts.
He drinks 70 something shots of eggnog and got over it.
Yeah,
I think that's a gallon dude.
Maybe seeing why do you think that?
Just because I don't count the Times to completely make it simple clue.
I would just think that if I bought a gallon of Eggnog and I poured 70 people
drinks from it,
I would be shut out of it.
I would be shocked at the economy of this gallon.
Yeah,
you're right.
he did it.
He did it.
He drank more than a gallon because half a path of Menarche.
Pat From Inaki.
Cause if you've watched the video of pat from Munafiki hurling and I'm not going
to play anything for you,
but you were there live with me.
I was their life.
We were there in those two her.
So it was Norton.
So as opie and Anthony was red band there to reverend was not there.
He was not there.
Holy Shit.
Was it crazy?
Oh my goodness.
The smell and Iraq was there.
They had a kid named Pat Duffy,
and this is what happened to folks.
They had a,
they had this nutty eggnog drinking contest and pat from Menarche,
who is a giant of a man,
he's an enormous,
and he was their claws,
but another giant of a man.
Huge,
enormous guy.
This a PAF would knock and he's the,
the current champs I,
he is keeping his fucking crown.
Okay.
By the way,
he's diabetic last two
immediately.
Oh,
he's so crazy by the way,
is by the way.
That's why,
okay.
Anthony is the most awesome Mr Radio show in the history of radio mean.
That's just who the fuck else would do that.
Maybe we'll stern would do that too.
So anyway,
they have this fucking guy,
Pat Boone knocky who was,
you know,
he,
he can only keep it in a system for a certain amount of time.
He's got,
otherwise he has to get rid of it.
He's got to die.
Well,
he's got to get rid of it cause he could die like literally from sugar himself.
Yeah.
He has to give himself a shot of insulin.
So this is,
I mean a massive amount of shit plant still winning.
He's still,
I'm in warrior so he um,
he says I'm going to,
I'm going to blow soon,
I'm going to blow soon.
And then somehow or another I get this crazy idea where I say,
how about somebody leans over the garbage can and opens their mouth and he
throws up in your mouth directly into your mouth.
And I'm thinking,
there's no way anybody,
I'm saying something ridiculous.
I'm saying something like when like when red bands on the podcast and he says,
why don't you just eat your own poop?
He doesn't really mean he shouldn't.
Trying to say something completely ridiculous for funny.
Okay.
That's what I was trying to do.
Yeah.
I was thinking just for a joke.
Huh?
Why don't I say you say something as a joke,
but they take a completely cereal.
This Pat Duffy motherfucker said,
I'm game.
This guy would do anything that would silence the room.
He would catch a bullet with his deck.
This dude's memorandum on him saying I game.
It was like a to be like what?
And then someone said someone's,
I don't remember if they said why it was happening.
Who named it?
The baby else.
It might've been,
it might've been if any brands but might've been Vinnie brand.
It was somebody else was there,
some other person was there and [inaudible] was there and I'm Burke came in just
cause he,
he,
he wanted the year before and he said,
I want to be a part of that one this year.
Those guys are so like no one will understand if you've ever done like a radio
show that's been like rigid and stiff and the people are nuts.
You'll never understand the ONA.
I of them,
I bought a baby bird tree shirt.
He said fucking only shirts online.
Here's another thing that happened on ONA.
We convinced Stalker Patty,
who's this crazy lady who comes to the studio.
It was like a 49 year old virgin and she's really nuts too.
We convinced her that she was on drugs.
We took a,
you're going to take a leak.
We don't,
we convinced her that,
um,
she had taken a drug that we had put a drug and,
no thanks man.
I'm good.
And completely psychosomatic started having massive hallucinations.
So Ari pulls his ball,
sack out your cock and balls or just your balls a cock cock and balls.
It could be.
And,
and she was sitting there like,
like we,
we,
we had a completely convinced with like sound effects and shit that she was just
tripping or balls,
put a rabbit Sudan on and run around the room once and then run out.
Who was that?
I don't remember,
but it was,
that was either Roland or Iraq.
I was one of those [inaudible] you rock.
It was good fun with a crazy person,
but what you did to take it to the next level,
so you pulled your cock and balls out,
which you probably can never do now because you did this before.
They,
uh,
got kicked off the air for that Condoleezza Rice thing
for them now.
Yeah.
That homeless guy said a lot of crazy shit like you wanted to rape Condoleeza
Rice and like you guys didn't even say that.
What did he say?
He said he wants to love her hard.
He wants to love her until she loves it.
Oh really?
Oh well that's in your window for rape.
Possibly.
I hear girls like that.
They like it if they love it.
I hear it too.
When they say I love when your heart like that,
but that's not um,
that's not rape.
Yeah.
Is that what he said for something like that?
It was just taken out of context.
He said way more fucked up than that.
I remember it being pretty racy and the queen to,
he was going to hold her down,
make her love lover.
The Queen,
Queen of England.
He's got hair is what he said.
Yeah,
I did think that's pretty funny.
Why would they a suspend the show for that?
That's so sad.
Yeah,
but you gave me a look.
I was sitting at that cause there wasn't a room you gave me.
I was sitting on the couch and you get,
she gave me a look and it was like,
oh my welcome to do things here.
And those guys open.
Antonio were so cool that I was like,
cause I knew I was only there hanging out with you,
but I was like,
I think they're okay if I play here.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they totally were.
Oh yeah.
Well they're all,
there's never like a level.
You're not,
that's a good,
they never do that shit.
Yeah.
That's a real good point.
Like,
Oh,
you're a comic,
you're finding his cool.
How are you?
Yeah.
And well that's how some of the best guests come about.
And then they've,
they've made some of their best kiss guest famous.
You know,
when I first started going to New York,
I couldn't get on their show man.
I was in Jersey.
Yeah.
That wasn't known enough.
You know,
I was doing,
when they already had a show back then they were doing the afternoons.
I know.
Really I would do a rascals rascal's comedy and I'm in Jersey,
I forget where it was.
Orange West orange he was doing,
yeah.
West orange and,
um,
really nice club.
And I,
but I,
you know,
it was hard to get people to come in back then cause I was a nobody.
I was like headlining,
but I was on like hardball,
you know what I mean?
Like,
no,
nobody knew who the fuck I was.
So I would do a show on,
it'd be half empty.
Um,
so,
but if you got to know being Anthony,
you pack that place.
Like they would always talk about Jay more.
Jay Moore did opie and Anthony and he would just pack the fucking club pack he
just wanted then,
yeah,
it was like,
well,
if I could get their god,
but I couldn't get on.
I wasn't,
I didn't have enough clout.
So once I started doing it,
it was like,
ah,
so fun.
You know,
they're,
they're nuts,
man.
They've done some nutty fucking stunts.
But this guy leaned over a trash camera,
tilted his head back like he was getting his hair shampooed at a barber pat from
[inaudible],
300 plus pounds of them.
This enormous man who has drank,
I believe it was 74 shots.
And I'm being conservative.
He beat the last guy that drank a couple more while the other guy got ready,
he beat,
he beat his own record and he was like,
yeah,
that's what he did.
He wants to be this record.
And it goes,
all right.
It's time.
And then was like,
all right,
that's about it.
That's all I got.
So I got,
and so this guy actually did what I suggested,
just Pat Duffy guy did lean over the barrel because that was the height of fear
factor.
So this,
it's like a perfect fear factor thing.
Exactly.
And Pat from would knocky did what can only be described as a comic book throw
up in this guy's mouth like,
and nowhere in the world has anyone thrown up on a person the way he did it.
There's no way it's been done as a still picture and it looks like he is
enveloping.
They've got like a spider breaking down with his fluids.
Say That Pat Flynn would knock.
He also was a competitive eater or wasn't a,
yeah,
yeah.
He didn't just win this eggnog challenge.
He's been,
he's done and stop the career.
Great career,
career and competitive eating,
where he's been fairly successful.
He's an extraordinary man when it comes to volume.
So he's got this killing it,
fucking this,
this broken fire hydrants spew coming out of his mouth where we're going.
And I mean,
and it lasts.
It lasts way more than should be real.
It seems like it's Photoshop.
If we weren't there and it wasn't from a bunch of different angles and Shitty
cell phone footage.
I think our version is that one of us had a cell phone there was recording it,
but it's,
it's so crazy.
It's so crazy that the volume is so insane.
It doesn't,
it's so cartoonish.
It's so comic bookish.
It's just bad.
It's the extra cyst.
I mean,
it's insane.
And then after we left and there's bars everywhere,
we were out of the studio 10 minutes later we're like,
hey,
Ron and fez enjoy this smell and no shit.
And just left it to him.
Yeah.
In these giant,
like big garbage pails filled with throw up and it's plastic all over the floor.
I mean Donk,
the air control come on and the waft would hit you where you're like,
Ooh,
it was chaos.
It was pre merger.
They had a lot more freedom back then.
You know the,
and that was,
that was the regular radio virgin,
right?
Yes.
That was f k Rock,
k Rock in New York.
God,
that was awesome.
There was so much fun.
And then the rest of the day we would like in bliss,
like she has to see something fucked up.
Yeah,
we saw something fucked up.
We were so lucky.
Equivalent.
I'm realizing it's not when you're talking about the bus room,
cause we were,
we were happy.
Yeah.
It's the equivalent of when a girl blows you in the morning.
Whoa.
And the rest of the day you just feel good.
That's pretty hot.
Yeah,
it is.
It's close to it.
Yeah.
We,
we had achieved this moment of like,
especially
comedians want to see fucked up things.
We want to see things at a reduced rate.
After that,
we had the whole thing with Jamie,
Jamie Masada from the laugh factory,
which is,
by the way,
dom just,
I did his,
his podcast over there and he goes,
while Jamie's there,
he goes,
Jamie,
how can we not put Arriann got a following up?
I put them on.
I'm like,
Dang,
that's cool if you don't,
but no,
you know,
you don't never hear.
Wow.
But like,
yeah,
but he's like,
okay,
I'll put you on.
And now he's like actively trying to get me in there.
That's beautiful.
Really Nice.
I'm going to do that.
Tom's a good guy,
man.
And Dom quits drinking.
He quit drinking recently and he's experienced like this rejuvenation and the
way he feels and about stand up comedy.
Yeah.
And doing the podcast a few times.
Stand up as a,
you know,
a lot of people coming out to see him from the podcast.
You know,
that they'd come up to him afterwards.
So yeah,
the,
the quitting,
the drinking things.
Fuck,
I'd have them on.
I probably go giants,
man.
Oh yeah,
you have mine.
He's a great guy.
He's an interesting dude too.
And Dom Irrera.
It's like the most honest,
don't give a fuck guy left on earth.
His famous line that I always quote,
uh,
is,
um,
uh,
I wish I was gay just so I could come out of the closet.
That's how little I give a fuck.
Anyway.
If you go to my website,
are the great for free tracks.
Go there and get four free drugs for nothing.
Are you coming with me afterwards here to go see my,
a studio?
Are you going to sue that?
Let's go see that movie.
One movie.
The one you were talking about.
Oh,
the Jewish welfare?
No,
the Will Ferrell movie.
Oh yeah.
I would go see that.
Okay.
Let me,
I might have to do some baby shit though.
You know,
little girls I might have.
I might have.
I have to remember whether or not a committed to doing okay.
Doing okay.
Sometimes I say,
okay,
well go do that later.
I mean,
I don't remember about it and then my wife has to go,
you promised you would do that later.
Like they get mad.
You can't disappoint he that shit.
Oh,
that was that.
Yeah,
they get,
they get a little shout out cause it means a lot to them.
That's the thing I'd be so worried about with kids.
You make an offhanded statement and they take it forever.
It doesn't matter.
You just,
you just,
you know,
Miss,
make sure that you don't disappoint them.
It's just,
it's more of a responsibility.
But the,
the reward of it is amazing.
It's hard to really wrap your head around cause I've been like you before,
you know,
I've been single and you know,
and to be like the last thing I want some form of care.
I believe me,
I was like the voice of that before.
Here's what it's like until you have that.
Okay.
But here I get that,
I get that there is a whole different side of it and there are benefits that I
can understand that and there's negatives that I can or anything like that.
Sure.
I'm just sort of wrap my head around,
but like,
um,
what was I going to say?
Fuck.
Oh,
hit the decision to whether or not you should have a baby should be thought of
that.
Should we thought up before randomly,
some girl says,
Hey,
I'm pregnant.
Oh yeah,
you should already be decided.
Can we have a baby now?
Or not?
Not like,
wow,
maybe we should do this.
That's not the right time to think about it.
Yeah.
My um,
the,
the two year old was the one that we did on purpose,
you know,
and it was like planned out and everything and I was happy for the other
daughter as well.
I mean,
super happy.
I met him when you told me about it as we were playing pool.
It was crazy,
but super happy.
But,
but planning for one is kind of a different thing.
Like you're planning,
how is it different and it sounds so good.
We're trying to get pregnant.
Like,
you know,
she's trying to get pregnant.
Stupid.
You're just fucking her.
Right.
You know what didn't we were trying were pregnant.
No,
you're not.
You're not pregnant.
That's the trade off.
Shut up.
We have to pay you alimony for fucking 40 years.
But we get to say we are pregnant.
It's just some bait,
a shit.
It's just some Beta shit that men fall into.
Once they get their wives pregnant and they become your testosterone drops.
It's really scientifically proven.
You mimic their behavior sort of.
Well,
you become a Nester.
You know your testosterone drops when you're a year round babies,
you were on your wife and it's also try to probably try to calm you down to make
you a little bit more patient.
Nature knows what the fuck is doing.
Am I ever,
I had a rabbi once in a sixth grade rabbinic a nutcracker.
But anyway,
he said,
ah,
the reason God makes babies cute so we don't kill them.
I used to do that in my arms.
I said,
the reason they like,
yeah,
we'll oxytocin.
It's oxytocin.
It's something that you,
your brain produces when you see your babies and the suits.
Credibles drawing of love and connection.
This,
this incredible drug.
It's the same drug that women,
uh,
that it's released in women when their orgasm and really joking my accident.
And then it's to keep you from eating when you get really hungry.
That's the reason why a baby produces oxytocin.
Like when you see them,
like you literally do that in you a drug.
Yup.
Yeah.
You literally get drugged.
I mean,
it's all set up.
It's set up so that we keep reading.
It's not a,
it's not a,
you know,
it's not,
uh,
an accident that when you're around a check,
your dick gets hard and get all attracted to her.
Like this girl that has a super powers that you're talking about,
you're talking about like a beautiful girl was like,
she just thinks she's got a superpower.
She can walk into a room and everybody wants to fuck around.
So she's confused and she acts crazy,
but no one cares the little jewelry,
anything because she's felt like Traci Lords,
I know there's nothing to alter their chemicals on you or this is new girl
that's hanging out at the store and she's a comic and everybody,
yeah,
everyone wants buyer and she's not super gorgeous and she doesn't dress slutty
already.
She's just dirty.
But yeah,
she's just dirty.
He said dirty and everybody walks by or,
and it was like,
who does that girls deal?
Like I've heard a thousand comics ask and it's just she's exuding something.
Some chemical.
Yeah.
There's girls that are just sexy man.
There's girls that are not that good looking,
but they're fucking give you a or something.
I don't know what it is.
And by the way,
Sax with them is always way better sex with a girl who's really pretty but not
into it and you to someone to be into it.
It's weird what once the guy's willing to fuck you,
let it all out.
Don't worry about like ocean,
look at this and that's what I'm talking about.
Let it go.
Let it go,
baby.
We're happier there and if he throws up,
he throws up.
Exactly.
Ain't Ganna.
The people used to love those points were really fat guys would fuck girls.
I remember there was a magazine called sluts and slobs.
That was what,
like looking at the girl Hako.
Yeah.
It was one of my favorite all time
because it was sloppy.
Who's dudes with like Spaghetti stains on tank tops and shit.
They were dressed as a slob.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The whole fantasy was that these dudes were just slinging Mike Blacks.
When we catch up with my black,
my blacks are fairly handsome man.
We're talking about like really fucking sweaty guys,
man.
Yes.
Yesterday we've had some good times on the road.
I'm crazy.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
Well,
the,
the comradery that comes from being a standup comedian,
it's like,
it's,
it's hard for a lot.
Like we talk about comedy all the time.
We talk about the art form of comedy and a lot of times people are like,
Ooh,
good Jews doing will come in to too much.
You got to understand that.
For us it's like,
it's,
I mean it sounds so stupid,
but it's almost like a sacred topic.
But also this things you can get from it too if you're listening through.
Wait,
Greg Jackson talks about it.
He always asked me questions about stand up.
Yeah.
He's always like,
so what did you do when you're not doing well?
What do you do?
He's in [inaudible] games.
Yeah.
But he's like,
he sees the similarities between what he's trying to train and what we're doing
and all the arts.
Well,
there's a similarity in truth,
if you don't hit the right notes and comedy,
it's clunky and awkward and we're the right steps on this.
Now we all know that like there's a bid,
the you've done,
everybody's got a bit that if you heard it today you would cringe because you
know it's clunky.
You got into a bad,
right.
Well that that used to be like,
like a approach that I would use with,
you know,
martial arts techniques.
Like I had some bad approaches that I had like when I was a blue belt or green
belt that I would use an intro right there,
would never use as a black,
they're,
they're terrible approach might work with full of mistakes.
Then you get,
Oh,
you know,
you just attack you,
you go wide open and still you can't do that.
You have to have faints and you have to have movement that you have to learn
what a throw a guy off and what doesn't throw a guy off.
And there's moments when you look back on the,
the beginning jokes,
just clunky,
dark.
Anyone's listening can relate to that.
And it's something that they've done where they were bad at something and cause
if you're not,
you're a bitch.
If you,
if you've lived your life and never got good at something with the funny thing.
Yeah,
yeah.
What have you done?
You crazy.
You've missed out on what's a look,
it's hard to do shit.
It's,
it's difficult and scary,
but that's what friends are for.
Friends,
cushion,
all that shit.
If you've got,
you know,
one of the things that Randy couture said it really kind of a cool thing that he
said about fighting.
He said that if you,
if you love your friends and love your family,
they're going to love you.
If you win and lose,
you don't have to worry about that,
but that is something that people think about.
Like you,
you base your worth and your value on winning and it becomes too much of a big
deal to you becomes like everything becomes your whole life.
I heard this about kids recently that you shouldn't say good job when I get a
good grade or something,
because that is an unintentionally instilling in them that they are only
successful in your eyes or are good in their eyes when they're winning.
So when you want to create a team full of pussies or what,
what the fuck are you?
I'm here in the baby books.
I think those baby books are written by cunts.
It's possible.
I don't know.
It was crazy.
Fuck heads who don't know shit about raising.
I'm just talking shit.
It's crazy.
People like to be reinforced.
I think positive reinforcement for for jobs was to do his job well.
Tried.
If they're trying hard,
that's what you're supposed to reward.
Nonsense.
Success.
That sounds like some socialists bullshit.
I went into cup target.
White liberals designed to slow down the marathon.
Somebody doesn't want to see a sub three hour marathon,
whatever mile I was trying to form into my four minute mile and a three hour
marathon.
I think they all run into three minutes.
Read Paul Ryan character.
No,
they don't all run like the champions.
I mean,
yeah,
I champion the 22 thirds.
That's why that Paul Ryan Dude tried to sneak in that he ran a sub three hour
marathon and they called him on it.
He didn't told no
more than four hours.
It was documented.
Are you going to vote this year?
No,
you're not going to.
I'm thinking of not voting.
You've said in the past you think it's all ridiculous.
This,
this is the,
they really believe that.
Then there's no reason to waste your day.
Then another day with your kids.
I think with the electoral college system,
it's in place and anybody that's telling me that Obama is better than Mitt
Romney,
then Mitt Romney,
he's the God damn Holocaust.
If that's what you're telling me.
If you're telling me that Obama,
that Mitt Romney is,
it's going to be worse than Obama and when you think about all the shit that's
happened in this country to civil liberties over the last couple of years,
whether people are aware of it or not,
it's almost like this country is tightening up and getting ready for civil war.
Like they're getting scared that there's going to be civil unrest.
So they're putting all these things in the place where they can spy on you and
all these things in place that are fucking completely unamerican and completely
unconstitutional.
And then they went and reread the constitutional rewrote rather the constitution
they took out thing.
The things that you like.
Posse comitatus I believe it is the head,
the ability to use the military to,
to stop civil unrest.
American military.
Yes.
The American military can now be used to stop civil unrest.
They can now arrest you for for Shit and they don't have to bring it to trial
and they can hold you as long as they want and you have no recourse.
This is all for American stuff so cause no,
cause someone's going to abuse that power.
Exactly who it is and they say they will never use it and Obama was like we'll
never use us.
It does.
Okay.
How about someone that's being born right now?
It grows up in 40 years to become the president.
You were saying you'll never use it.
There's a reason why we had all this shit set up on a long time ago to make sure
that you didn't involve church and state.
I think we've got to rewrite the constitution.
Of course we do.
We write a brand new one cause that stuff that happened to him,
it go,
it has nothing to do with us.
He can't have a constitution that was written before the Internet.
That's nonsense.
The ability for electricity.
Yeah.
Well the,
you know,
look they had,
they knew the concepts of classic societies.
They knew,
they knew the concepts of what was,
what was going to cause people to fall apart.
What's going to cause people to give in to their,
ed was going to cause people to,
to be corrupt and to,
to,
to go wrong.
And so they presented all that shit.
They prevented freedom.
So we just gotta be able to say whatever the fuck you want to say.
You can't stop people from talking.
You got to let people express themselves.
You get a lot loud people to protest.
You have to allow people to organize.
You've got to let them be armed.
There's all these things they sent in place cause they knew because they know if
you're going to all your,
we have none,
you're going to abuse that and that's something that liberal people don't want
to accept.
The problem in this world is the gun prop know their problems and all this is
crazy people.
You have to allow for that.
There will be people you might not,
but some people will and so then you have to defend yourself.
You have to,
if that's it,
another sickness,
higher door.
It's a sickness and society that we have to address.
Why are we creating sick people?
Why are we creating crazy people?
Why are we creating violent people and that can be resolved with time and
education and some form of action,
some form of social engineering.
I believe that you're going to be able to at least cut significantly down on the
amount of constant douchebags that are developed by,
by a civilization.
I think if we went from being barbarians to people that live in a more civilized
now,
way more civilized obviously,
right?
It's not even close.
So if you just extrapolate a hundred years into the future,
you would assume that things will continue to get easier and easier and easier.
Yeah,
I got think that eventually we can do,
but you know,
we're never gonna be able to engineer out greed.
We're never going to be able to engineer out.
If someone has to complete and total control over an entire city,
they will do something terrible.
They just,
that's human nature.
I just say that it's like,
hold on.
Why would you say you would never do that when so many people have done it?
You should say,
I'm glad I don't have
that power because I probably would abuse it.
Right?
Because if you look at like what we've done,
you know,
as a human race,
we're just in a military means or by military means over the last decade,
how much different is it really?
Then what happened during the days of the barbarian hordes?
You know,
the numbers are probably more significant.
Like it seems more civilized in the surface,
but they're more effective at killing people.
They can kill massive numbers of people with like a bunch of people.
Just died the other day.
I think it was in Yemen where they,
they,
they shot a bunch of civilians with one of those fucking drones and they just
killed 14 people,
14 civilians.
I mean,
women and children and they're getting jacked constantly by these things.
The whole thing.
There's thousands of people been killed by these drones.
Wow.
That's,
that's a,
that's how they want to outlaw up because that just allows for error too easily
and no one has to like feel it.
Well,
no one's,
there's no significant voice to outlaw these things.
Really.
I've heard people say those,
those,
that's one of the things I've heard about,
but yeah,
not in this country,
man.
You don't hear Mitt Romney saying it.
We're going to stop.
The drones were going to stop those drone attacks.
No,
no,
no.
Pick it.
Or people will say,
oh,
those people don't have a say so you don't have any silly picutre people stoke
those people.
He said,
do you think,
um,
President Bush,
this is how long it was.
He goes,
do you think President Bush cares about US protesting the war?
I think he thinks about the protesters,
the way we feel about the WWE Mba.
Like,
sure,
it's annoying,
but let them feel like they're making a difference.
Oh my God,
I can't believe you went there was pick her up,
retire from comedy.
Why do you retire?
It wasn't making him happy after awhile.
He just wasn't making money at it and he was like,
I got to do something when I'm on a struggle for fucking one 45 spots in the
store.
A lot of guys get close.
The grind is hard,
man.
The fucking,
the grind.
When you're especially a grind in la,
when you're like one of those up and coming comics,
so you don't even ever like road gigs.
He can pick up for 50 bucks here and there.
One time I perform for free for someone.
Yeah,
I should.
You know how in the running and there's an explosion behind your or tidal wave
coming at you or like the bridges falling behind you and people behind you were
falling in,
but you managed to make it off before it completely collapses.
That's how I view a standup comedy where there's some funny people that just
didn't get a living enough to get them going and they fell off the bridge.
Yeah.
I mean it's like anything else.
We all sucked at it at the beginning of just get,
it's the reason why you can equate standup comedy to martial arts is cause it's
two things that you have to look at really realistically.
In order to get better at them,
you've got to figure out how to fucking make your way through the maze.
And if it gets to me pregnant early,
it's going to be a lot harder.
Fuck yeah,
it is.
You know,
you might've quit.
I almost definitely would have quit if I got somebody pregnant 26 a year end.
But you think you would take you to take some time off?
For sure.
Who comes back after time off?
Who knows?
Like in a ghoul did really?
Yeah.
Dana Gould took a long time off.
He was writing for the Simpsons.
Yeah.
But that it was raising kids too.
I Dunno,
I might've made that up.
Imagine if he's gay.
I'm just making sure he wasn't going to get a dog.
I think it does hinder my story teller show.
Really cool.
He was one of those guys that was around,
uh,
in Boston.
He was ahead of me.
He was like a couple of years ahead of me.
I don't think he's coming to your professional.
No.
He comes back like a lineup.
Like Mary Lynn comes back that,
but they,
once they give it up,
you're never back in it.
Not the same to,
you know,
it's just like dead.
Your heart's not in it.
You're double.
Your performance isn't as good.
Yeah.
These once in a month.
The people like us that are like real hardcore standup fanatics,
like we despise people that quit.
You quit and plus he tried to be like,
oh no.
Well I'm glad you're happy.
You're happy now.
You know,
we're looking at you like
you're giving up the greatest drug in the world.
It's just he can't take the ride.
The ride is just to bumping you pussy,
but just like though you're not one of us anymore.
It's where the grant,
how could you not be one of us along?
Yeah.
I gotta be careful when I'm around guys like stand up or stand hope rather.
What?
Cause I wanna start doing mushrooms in front of them.
You want to start around a guy like that?
You'll just do more,
do mushrooms and drive home and drive home.
Yeah.
It's a problem.
That's a problem if you like.
I kind of,
I haven't had the training he has.
Yeah.
One of our friends,
which we'll go,
let's say he wrote his name rhymes with Smitty.
Wavo yeah.
Was on a crazy mushroom dose and he was driving home and the the road in front
of them turn into flower petals.
Oh my God.
It's like as he was driving it,
it's just flowers are flying off of his wheels and flowers were in front of
them.
Yeah.
Could you imagine it wasn't that bad but just once where his dry.
I thought it was done because I was doing it in someone's apartment.
Um,
and that was all right.
I'm good.
I'm going to go home and spend five hours and then I'm driving.
I was looking at a sign,
but it's like,
that's like that picture behind you.
It has a lot of colors and it just starts swimming.
When I was at the light,
like everything started,
then I was like,
oh fuck,
do noon.
Do I feel like it's too dangerous to drive on?
Oh Fuck,
wait,
I'll do it.
Mushrooms,
mushrooms are real.
Uh,
it dissipates reality.
It gets reality to a place where you're like,
I don't know if you can manage this.
You,
you,
you might be experiencing something that's absolutely not there at all.
Yeah.
You could just drive over a fucking cliff.
Think you're on a water ride.
You know,
you never quite lose reality,
but you sort of get close.
Like you don't lose where you are.
100% I'm going to cap city,
by the way.
When are you working there?
Two weeks.
The 14th I think.
September 14th let me see.
Nice.
So number 14 says that shit,
what days are you there?
The the 12th or 13th Oh,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday,
four days to four days.
The 12th through the 15th.
Holy Shit Dude.
You're a legit comic.
Now you are,
you're a legit headline in places.
Now it's religion.
How many fucking cool man and the Cap City Comedy Club in Austin,
Texas.
That's legitimate gets man as a standup comedian that and the comedy works in
Denver.
Do you want to talk about like the independent clubs that are like super legit
Yap city.
It's a super legit,
you're there.
You're a rear rear real comic.
There's five rooms that I put on my like my favorite five rooms for like a long
time.
Yeah.
Um,
or the comedy store cap city.
Denver comedy works.
These improv just cause it was my first road rules as far as the vibe as hot
room and throw Austin might have the best vibe in the history of the universe.
That's so cool.
That's why we filmed that.
Um,
uh,
what,
what did we call it?
My butthole video.
Oh yeah.
When you had a problem going to be called the Juke plan,
did you chlamydia your booty hole problem?
Um,
in the green?
Are they?
Yeah,
it's just an awesome,
they're cool.
They're one of the cities that that gets it.
They're smart enough to get it but cool enough to be laid back about it.
But so many fucked up in that club and painted over all the writing and the
green room asshole decided there was too much writing on the wall.
You had like two,
two 30 years of history that some,
it was fun.
It was awesome.
Any body,
some dummy.
There was people that were dead that wrote on that wall.
A lot of them including Hedberg.
Ah,
who do pay.
So silly bitch.
How dare you.
You fuck heads.
That was historic.
It's not a story cause they Atlanta punchline cause the Atlanta punchline has
that one thing he says quit trying to be Hicks.
You know if you're writing on a wall.
So I was going to write something shitty.
So many dudes try to be Higgs hits as far as like influencing comedians.
Hicks influenced comedians the wrong way more than anybody.
Yeah.
Kaufman Kaufman was pretty bad.
But they did not likely to go on stage and like self righteous.
That's it.
To the crowd.
I didn't do that.
They didn't think they were better than you because they're trying some
experimental.
Yeah,
well not only that,
like some shit they just wrote in Popular Science magazine,
five minutes again,
they're yelling at the crowd that they don't know it because you're at home
watching fucking Roseanne
and then they always do that.
They always say that a lot of times they'll be like,
oh,
too edgy for you.
Nope.
No one laughed because it wasn't funny.
Just sucks.
Stupid.
Too Edgy for you.
How come you didn't fucking dummy jump it and Bob on stage eight times in a row
on purpose just for the sake of it.
Just get fucked.
Know this.
That's just as fake is like fake clean comedy.
Yeah,
exactly.
I have no thoughts about,
yeah,
it's just,
it's in part of it is,
you know,
sometimes people don't look at themselves that objectively,
so they don't know that what they're putting out there so stupidly offensively
dumb.
They don't know.
They didn't even know just to just clunk,
clunk,
clunk.
It's,
it's,
it's hard when you watch them and go on stage.
I,
I worked in Vegas with this guy once.
He was supposed to do like 20 minutes.
He did 45 45 minutes and it was the,
or some of the worst fucking comedy I have ever seen in my life.
It was so bad that by the time I got on stage,
I was like,
there's nothing funny.
There's nothing.
Nothing is funny.
Oh,
nothing.
Couldn't believe in fun.
It's like when we have together,
like we do gigs in the ice house,
especially like if we're on a board mood.
Yeah.
But,
but when we're doing that,
we're in a good mood.
We're shooting the shit,
and then we go on stage and you're like,
so many things are funny.
Yeah.
There's some of the best shows up.
There's funniness everywhere.
But if you're working with someone who sucks it,
it's like if you're at a job with someone who's a Douche bag,
it's difference between being
in a job and someone who's fun.
Like if you had to work with Joey Diaz all day,
he'd be laughing.
I mean,
once a month he'd yell at you,
but you got to deal with that mostly.
Great.
He'll yell at me over like fucking nonsense.
There was the one day that he came in,
it was fucking screaming about ranch dressing,
fucking branch stretching.
Somebody gave him ranch.
Well it was just tying me to a tee shirt about,
he sold like a thousand fucking tee shirts.
It's a,
it's blue cheese with wings or go fuck your mother was this famous line.
He just gets so mad about blue cheese,
blue cheese please.
That kind of guy.
You know like that's the kind of,
you know,
to be able to hang out with people like that.
Like this is a lot of people that would never understand a guy like that.
But for a guy like us,
like a standup,
another standup comic,
cause like I talk about a buoy in the ocean.
Like it's like you,
you,
you're gravitated towards him to save.
You mentioned him at Ona.
I mentioned deals cause I was like,
yeah,
told me this thing wants,
they're like,
oh yeah,
junk.
How's that?
We haven't seen him in forever.
They're like,
he's so good at telling stories.
And I'm like,
yeah,
sure.
Fucking is.
He sure is.
He's an unusual Newman.
So important to to find those fucking people so hard.
It's one thing that I've developed a skill for.
I know how to wrangle people together and not to wrangle a bunch of cool people
together.
It's hard.
It's hard to find like cool,
interesting people.
It's hard to like a cream that I've got.
Yeah,
you got a cut all the cons out.
You got to cut them all out.
It's like pruning a tree.
It's hard.
The problem is it's hard with them concert,
like somehow related to the cool people who,
yeah,
that's probably like,
oh,
that's your best friend or brother or a mess.
And you're like,
oh,
so he comes with you,
but I don't want him.
I just want you.
And he's like snipey.
He says snipey Shit,
girlfriends,
shitty parents,
something like that.
Yeah.
And he was like,
I don't want to hang out with them at all.
You don't have to do their actual words.
Just there's a balance.
This world,
man,
people don't realize it.
Those,
those country people does it directly.
Their consciousness directly proportionate to how happy they just walk away from
it.
Now I treat them as like wild animals.
Like if there was a dark,
a barking dog,
I would cross the street before going in front of that yard.
It's just like,
I'm not going to dismiss them.
Oh,
what the fuck is this?
Do you have any interests?
I bought a ticket for you of Louis Saint Louis C k doing new stuff tonight.
Um,
at the comedy store may room.
Ooh,
I might be into doing that.
I got to see it.
You're going to say we'll get off the podcast.
Okay.
It's at midnight when she made this like oh wow.
That's pretty lame.
Yeah.
Why is he doing a show at midnight?
Is doing an early show to Nope,
just to let you off doors up on 11.
Huh?
I think it was already showing there and he goes,
I don't want to blow up so it out late,
so fuck it.
Let's the two legs.
It's awesome.
New Jokes.
So it's,
it's so cool that he's doing that man.
And he said,
you can take a week,
only buy tickets live and I'm with cash so that nobody counterfeits anything.
Whoa.
So the door guys have this like stay there and like sell tickets like in the
cover book.
So nobody counterfeits anything.
How you guys deal with not counterfeiting?
Scalping.
Oh yeah.
He's had to deal with that a lot I guess.
So he's trying to overcome that with the tickets.
So you have to actually wait in line to buy the tickets?
No,
just walk up to the booth,
get them over.
That means you're,
I was going to be aligned.
It was no credit.
Put it online and there was no more than a 3% line.
They're just whipping people through.
Really?
Yeah.
And there's an ATM right on the corner right next to the main road is an ATM
there paying gold.
I don't know.
It's so weird.
It's like cash.
I was like,
do I have the cash on me?
I guess.
Sounds like he's going to get robbed.
Yeah.
What is someone's gangster and then that neighborhood,
they know there's a lot of cash now son.
You gave up the goods.
You notice that gangster has become a black guy or it used to be like a Italian.
Yeah,
gangster.
Yeah.
They took it.
They did another thing.
They've stolen things besides our wallets.
Whoa.
Alright.
That was like sounded too hard.
Well,
let's salt in me.
I did.
This guy wants something good,
but I didn't know the line.
We're talking about rookie mistakes and stuff,
right?
I didn't know the line of how you can like be mean,
but say it in a smile.
I learned a lot from watching don bears.
What do you call these grandmothers?
Like filthy whores.
But he'd do it with such a smile.
I don't know how we quite exudes this like I'm clearly joking.
These old ladies would love it.
They'd be howling in front of their granddaughter.
It was just great.
I could always see him do it.
Barris knows how to do it.
Yeah,
well,
I say experience performing and I would do it sometimes with black people,
like what's that black people,
but say it in a friendly enough way.
They was all cool.
I remember this one door guy one time,
saw this black lady in the front row and goes,
what's up you black bitch?
Oh my God.
Well,
it cleared the room for the entire night for the next five hours.
Everybody was having weird sets.
Wow.
Yeah.
That can happen man.
When people can be like a little off cause it's something fucked up.
Someone says,
yeah.
So some guy came in one time with his girlfriend,
I was on stage at the store in middle of the show room.
It's fine to come in lair and uh,
I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
How are you?
Nice to see with your whore.
And I was like,
and the guy's like,
what the fuck's your problem?
And I had to like,
damn it,
now I'm stuck in this thing.
Yeah,
you're just trying to come up with something funny to say that you didn't get to
say it wrong.
It's sometimes they come out and you're like,
nope,
that wasn't it.
That didn't sound,
you know,
especially when you do like what you and I do,
which is like you go,
you go on stage,
he does a lot of fucking around.
There's a lot of ad libbing and that's how you come up with new material,
you know,
to get like the,
the bridges between subjects like sometimes are different every night,
you know,
and in doing keeps it loose and sound natural and conversational.
Yeah.
And sometimes in doing so,
you also create these like weird improvisational paths.
Will you go on some completely new angle?
You're like,
oh my God,
this is the new part to the bit,
this is important.
So yeah,
I,
it's important to me to be able to fuck around,
but sometimes,
you know,
especially when you,
if you have a new subject,
you're not exactly sure where you go and you just take a stupid kids and you're
like,
oh no,
like two minutes on a dark path.
And you're like,
oh,
there's a wolf around here to eat me a wolf,
a board.
I'm on the crowd who just get fucking stuck.
They're
stuck in a shit topic.
You ever start a topic and then you're in the middle of it and you want to bail.
They're like,
no.
Yeah.
And you go,
God,
do I get out of this?
I told him that the laugh factory the day I do and one of their employees shows,
uh,
I started down a path and I was like,
you know what guys?
I don't want to do that.
I this whole thing about this,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to talk about something else.
And I'm like,
all right.
Wow.
That's funny.
It was already getting laughs he was already doing to mine.
I was just like,
Nah,
that's funny.
Yeah.
I guess it all depends on your level of enthusiasm.
I got 12 minutes there and this is a seven minute bit,
so it's like,
do I want to commit this brooch percentage of this,
this time to this?
What made you decide to bail on it?
I wanted to work on something else.
Oh.
And there was like,
I could just do this right now,
but it'd be just me just doing it right,
right,
right.
I need to work on this other thing.
You know?
It's pressure where it's like,
that's my plan.
I needed develop things,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the way to go,
man.
Do you do spend a lot of time actually writing,
not actually writing.
All right over like notes,
little notes.
Get get in front of your computer and get high and just start writing and just
takes a while and don't try to write jokes.
So he was trying to write,
just write and just sometimes I write as stand up,
but sometimes I write as like if someone was reading a book but you,
there's things that come out and just start writing to start writing and then
we'll see what happens.
Cause these things that come out when you're doing that,
when you're,
there's things that come out and you put yourself in a place,
right?
Will you caught it comes out everywhere it comes.
Like comic comedy will come out when you drive in your car,
you'll have an idea,
but you have to write it down.
But when you actually force yourself to sit down and think about things,
it's not always that it works.
We actually put the time in.
Yeah,
I got a new bit right now,
man,
that I am so fucking happy with.
Oh my God.
It's destroying and it's something that I wrote.
I wrote on a plane and I,
and it,
it came to me.
It's one of the rare moments where it came to me with almost too much stuff.
There's too many punchlines.
It's just two killer cause it's too much.
It's is this subject that I am,
I'm really pissed off about.
And so it's like a 10 minute subject and I just have to keep remembering it
because it's brand new.
But it's like,
and there's this one boom and then this one.
Wow.
It's like I've got this new,
which to me is even more fun because you're excited about it.
That's why they killed him.
Oh it's cause like I really feel great but there's no acting in me at all.
It's all pure emotion.
It's pure emotion and the,
it's,
it's right.
It's on something,
something that's got something to it.
Some instead of clear to me a little bit was when Tom was telling me about
something,
Bill Byrd told them about writing new material.
Right.
And he was like,
how do you write that long?
And he broke it down to like five minutes a month,
which always embarrassed as everybody.
Yeah.
Um,
but then he's like,
where do you come up with?
It goes,
I don't know.
Stuff like,
what do you care about?
And you're like,
yeah,
that's it.
Just what do you care about?
That's all it is.
What's on your mind?
What's going on?
Traffic?
What's,
what's,
what do you care about lately?
Yeah.
The fucking line.
This place
or the bad foods you're supposed to eat or not supposed to eat or just whatever.
Right.
And you gotta be paying enough attention to attention.
Yeah.
And that's what's interesting.
What's interesting is always where if it could just be about the way your sheets
bunch up on you,
if that's what really makes you angry or happy or whatever,
then that's what you care about it.
That's okay.
Maybe the song.
Yeah.
You'd have to be really
interesting.
I don't want to be really good.
Those sheets,
I would way rather hear about competence like Jim Gaffigan,
we can make bacon funny.
That's true for like Jim Gaffigan could make sheets funny too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No for him,
it's just not for me or for you.
Right.
It wouldn't work,
but yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's what's what,
you know,
and that's what defines you is makes you interesting or not.
And it's like what kind of things are used to things that are on my mind.
That's what I'm talking about.
Standup comedy.
Ari Shaffir,
Cap City Comedy Club does September what,
what other days?
It's the 12th through the 15th keep it together,
mother fuckers.
Man.
It's a dark road out there,
ladies and gentlemen,
but we're all on it.
It's not even dark.
It's actually pretty awesome.
If you lived in the Annapolis Christi Dallas and somebody who can transport you
to today and living in a fucking dream.
Oh yeah.
Be totally different.
Right.
Ice Patches.
Madison,
how about just penicillin?
How about when you have sex with dirty prostitute?
You don't die.
Wouldn't that be sweet?
That'd be sweet if he just didn't die.
Yeah.
One day we'll have like you'll catch like gonorrhea and instead of having Chad
that thing and you just go whatever it,
I'm just gonna read that they raped the wand over you like star Trek,
you'll do it.
It'll be an APP on your cell phone.
You stick your,
your cell phone near deck and an accurate,
it'll zap it.
It's ridiculous.
We live in the best fucking time ever and everyone's depressed.
Why?
Because look at our future.
It's fucking Mitt Romney guy.
He's going to win two white people were angry.
You think their mom's going to win?
That's fucking,
that's how the place supposed to play out.
It doesn't matter.
Corporations,
when no matter who is in place,
and that's the only reason why gold ridiculous corporations are winning and what
really matters,
man is state and local elections and your friends and people you care about us
and what you do for a living.
You dirty bitch,
enjoy yourselves because you're not going to make a big difference in the
fucking way.
Even if he this,
this still just a person,
you,
you just want to do it and you'll be dead and gone forever,
so enjoy it while you're here.
The only way we can make a difference is talking about shit and having a new
generation of people who don't grow up to become the concept of the people that
are running this country are.
That's the only way.
It's the only way.
So by this conversation,
by this podcast alone influenced the youth or should fear and set them in a good
direction.
But you also didn't relate to on Yom Kippur.
Please get my album a revenge for the Holocaust.
What a perfect time to launch a comedy out,
but with you as a spider with us started David Juice,
firefighting Hitler and a,
that's going to be available on iTunes and already the great.com is his website.
Seal your website or ours?
The great.com they're both,
they're the same.
Sorry,
I should go to the same thing.
Yeah,
I like already the great though.
It's cool.
Also,
I'm sending you for Mp3s,
me,
anybody who goes to my website.
Oh,
there you go.
Awesome.
Well go to [inaudible] website are the great.com and get yourself some fucking
mp3s.
It's some solid Goddamn standup comedy for one of the best the country.
I've seen him develop from a goddamn hat to a real professional father that got
along.
No,
no,
I'm happy as a friend though.
I think it's awesome as far as I asked my rabbis about this.
Like when you come to Israel and then the people start to get more religious
than you feel like you've accomplished something and he's like,
yeah,
you,
he's like,
you help build something.
Well,
I definitely,
I'm happy when I'm around,
uh,
comedians and I give him advice and they get better,
but they don't,
and not everybody listens.
You,
you listen better than anybody that ever took on the road with me.
If I would tell you,
I'm like,
you got too many words in that man,
you would like,
you're right.
Fuck.
And you would just go sharpen it up and think about it and Redo things.
You know,
people have told me things that I didn't want to hear and some of them I fought
and some of them I listened to.
Some of them were uncomfortable,
but ultimately people especially in the beginning can like point things out to
you.
It's up to you whether or not you can see them and listen.
Looking down the whole time Mark Madison told me that I used to do that to look
up.
You're talking to the crowd.
I was like,
Oh yeah.
It helps.
Just little things like maybe you're right instead of fuck you.
You don't know what they're talking about.
I looked down way too much for a long time.
I did it for years.
Think what if it's not good or bad that you'd do that?
Yeah,
that this,
that you were wrong in the past.
What if it's just you can improve?
Yeah,
just do it like that.
But you were really good at listening and you were really good at changing to
taking chances.
You know?
That's why you're,
you're still producing like constant new material.
This.
If there's anything that always bugs us about someone that we know.
It's a guy who's got the same jokes for 10 years on sad.
It's like,
man,
you don't have anything new to say.
You got to have some new shit,
man.
He's good.
I've heard that to have some new shit.
You know a case.
That's the reason I shaved my beard is cause dice was the last straw because I
shave your beard.
I was like,
why is like for your act?
And I was like,
whoa.
And then it was like instead of like you're a doofus dice like he always is.
Right.
I was like,
if Andrew dice clay,
the legend of Andrew dice clay is telling me this is good for my act,
I'm like,
hey,
why?
And he goes,
you're expressive and people can see their expressions and I was like,
it doesn't make sense,
but I want to stop that you looked like a crazy dirt bag.
Crazy beard.
And I think that might be worth,
that might be worth more.
I see my expression,
the whole beard moves.
Yeah.
I don't think of dice.
I don't think dice gets that.
I wanted to get rid of dirt bag.
Look,
definitely look younger.
Isn't it weird you look younger though?
Everybody always says that when you shave your beard,
you look younger,
but you really do,
for whatever reasons,
more innocent babies are crying.
Shit's going on.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
tomorrow we will uh,
join freeway,
Ricky Ross,
the real Rick Ross.
He's joining us again on the podcast.
Tell us a little bit,
and that's the fake Rick Ross.
Yeah.
You've got the real one.
We've got the real one.
The Guy who this guy pretended is pretends to be the guy who went to jail for
selling cocaine,
cocaine sales funded the conscious versus the Sandinistas Nicaragua.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's how the day,
that's a whole Ollie north thing.
They were funneling,
they were selling drugs and they raised money for it.
Like having a bake sale with coke,
with coke.
And they would,
so they would get the coke,
Bravo America.
Two ways to think outside the box,
get the coke to the poor communities.
Wow.
And,
uh,
and everybody,
when
we all go dense,
and so this guy got out of jail and there's a rapper that's got his name.
I mean his,
his name is Rick Ross,
and he was freeway Rick Ross.
He was known as being this huge,
I mean,
I remember I asking me to killed anybody ever know.
He never got that disrespectful.
Okay.
I wouldn't do that.
But the guy has been in the,
you know,
he was in the drug trade for years,
got all over the news.
I mean it was like a big deal.
It's like one of those things like when rappers call themselves Capone Capone,
is he the one that was on Time magazine with like drugs?
I don't think holding them up,
but that's when the government,
they'd go back to that guy.
I don't think so.
No,
I don't think that's the case.
Um,
he was,
uh,
he was trying to stay like as low key as possible now,
but he got busted.
But,
uh,
the story is just insane.
He's kind of wrapper that's,
he's out.
He's out in free and this rapper out there,
his name.
Yeah.
And so he's like trying to sue them.
Just the same name,
like no,
here's my personality.
Or taking,
yeah.
Well they're not only was even crazier,
the rapper or used to be a corrections officer.
Oh really?
He was a prison guard,
which is really nutty.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's the whole thing is carets it's building.
His album was like the greatest thing of all time.
He's on the cover of Rolling Stone magazine.
Look around right there.
Right behind you.
Look at that rolling stone.
You see that rolling stone?
That's him.
Then I bought that rolling stone just for the real Rick Ross cause to talk about
it.
He's got it.
He's got tattoos of Abraham Lincoln from the dollar bill.
You have a five and George Bush.
George is blocking him from the one.
Yeah.
That's a new thing that black dudes are doing.
Is it covering their whole bodies?
I agree.
Black dudes look better and tats,
but this is a weird goes with the skin.
Better rapper thing.
When they cover everything and they go,
they covered their face and they kind of,
there is the back of his poem all tatted up.
It's got a weed leaf on it,
but that didn't exist before,
isn't it?
You go back to like the superfly days,
they have to keep outdoing each other.
I did a joke that never was able to work,
but it's like every fucking granted mother has a tattoo now.
It's not a big deal.
So now we're going to have to do is go to the next stage,
which is what?
The ear things.
You know that your thing,
they push out.
Yeah.
And so then that's going to become blood today and then we're gonna have to do
the plates that the African people hadn't had x.
We're going to see that in our lifetime,
so we're going to have a place.
So like especially famous dudes to doing a lot of face tattoos.
Yeah.
A lot of like stars and shit and like I like it.
It's like fuck it.
I'm not going to have a regular job.
When do got an ice cream cone on his face.
I remember that.
Who's that guy?
Some rapper.
Yeah.
It's not a white thing.
No.
Well you could,
you could.
You know you'd be,
there was a guy or a bodybuilder that I saw at the airport that had a whole face
tattoo.
He got a Tyson thing,
one of those New Zealand Tyson Tattoo things.
The grief that you're great joke about it.
It was like,
if you're going to face that too,
because you want no interaction with any other human forever or something along
those lines.
Something along those lines.
Yeah.
It's obvious.
You want to scare everyone.
You come in contact,
you know?
Yeah.
It's in a weird,
we like,
we have certain spots in our body that means certain things.
If you start tattooing your face,
we've all agreed.
No,
no,
you get nutty son.
But over here on the wrist,
that's okay.
Oh,
that's nothing.
That's cute.
The ankle.
It's sweet.
You know the,
the chain link around the BICEP.
Yeah,
that one.
You can't get these rooms.
We
all bro.
That shit.
Solid steel.
Barb wire,
solid steel door
already.
The great.com you dirty bitches.
Follow Ari on Twitter.
Ari Shaffir with two apps.
That's a r.
Do too.
Good luck with the CD.
And I got like 10 weeks on the road coming up.
Check my website for all of when you leave and when he leaving for the road.
I've got a wedding this weekend,
but then the next one is the 12th or the 14th [inaudible] you gone like weeks at
a time.
Where are you going to do that thing?
Are you going to do it and why?
I'm doing,
I'm Toronto and then straight to Indianapolis.
That's a 10 day run,
but the rest of them are all back seats come in right before Toronto.
Maybe we can,
are you going to be here at at all?
Yeah,
right.
Unfortunately Toronto days,
three days before that.
So let's do that.
Let's do another one.
Let's do another podcast because that's right before.
And by the way,
that's the,
I'll have my studio up and running by then.
Okay.
At least the beginnings of it.
I,
you know any inputs you got on Twitter?
Anybody knows anybody who knows anything about building a studio.
Cause I got a dope ass office space now.
Nice.
Oh,
it's going to be killer dude.
Maybe that Tuesday after,
after this,
after punchdrunk.
I can't wait to have like a,
it's going to be like a raven night social clubs sort of a thing.
What I'm saying?
What do you mean?
Like just the way he said it.
Like have loungy places and have beers.
That'll Fred table there.
I'm a full table,
their couch,
big screen TV.
I'm going to have it a real cool spot and then I'm going to have the studio like
were where everybody sits down as comfortable as possible.
I think we figured it out now.
I think in doing the Ice House studio and doing this studio and you know doing
like Dunkin set up and doing my old set up,
we know what you need.
Yeah.
It's like the way that it brought Todd glass and to tell them how to build
helium or different clubs.
It's like,
no,
I know what's necessary.
Please trust me.
I've been through it so I waited till yeah,
comfort you and you can't have like loungey chairs.
You've got to have officers.
These are the kinds of chairs and these,
these microphones are real good,
but the better ones are.
There's a,
there's other ones that I've got here.
Just fucking,
you know,
this is a little weird.
It's tough cause its shores or like less directional.
This is a,
this has too much of a sweet spot.
And then there's another one that's don imus uses this thing.
I here,
it's a built in sound good.
I'm gonna try these names and these are the ones that we have the ice house but
I'm also going to try,
um,
there's ones that I saw on the dawn I,
my show,
I forget the names of them,
but they are the supposed to be the best for that kind of shit for radio.
And you don't have to put a windscreen over.
I'm,
and maybe you get a clearer sound.
Some people don't like the windscreen because it's like,
it gives you a little bit of a filter at sac.
We sounded like Kevin Smith,
he takes the,
the windscreen when he came over.
He doesn't get that though.
No,
he knows how to do it.
He knows how to manage it,
but it just feels like it's really him that way.
Otherwise,
this is like a muted,
I don't like the headphones sometimes.
Why is that one?
That hurt my ears,
but I have my glasses on.
So do you hear a difference between this and this?
Is there a difference?
Yeah,
there's a total difference.
that sounds better actually.
It sounds clear.
God dammit.
These fucking stupid condoms.
You know,
you've got these Pete Piper pots of pipe or whatever.
Say something like that with a lot of p's or teasing it.
Peter Piper.
Impact of pickled.
It sounds better.
It's a little bit hot,
but not mine.
It sounds like a real person,
right?
Yeah.
The MIC is on stage.
I don't have windscreens.
Sometimes they do on top of any rights,
but those aren't good.
Yeah,
this sucks.
It's wearing my windscreens up.
Maybe I'll try it with Erin told you to get something.
He probably told you get to the second best thing though.
We held,
held back,
whatever the first best thing now.
He was very,
very nice about it.
I want no fire to this.
He was very forthcoming.
Now I saw some,
I saw him,
I gave him a hug in Burt's on last night at the UCB and Burt said,
it goes,
if Mark Marin is the nicest person there,
something's wrong.
There's an attitude going on.
Yeah.
Everybody says that about the UCB.
I don't go there.
I don't know how much perceived that haven't been there before,
but I remember reading like,
um,
something somewhere where it was like a forum,
like a forum blog or something like that,
or forum posts were seeing.
I said,
why is Joe Rogan at the UCB?
It was like,
Hey,
when you do that once,
what is it that's so weird?
Like what was Matt put it together.
It was just like a good show.
That's not what I mean.
I mean,
it's,
it's so weird.
There's a type,
when they know about this type goes here and that's how it goes there and be
like,
dude,
there's a lot of overlap already.
Stevens is everywhere.
It's so silly.
It's so silly,
you know?
Yeah.
I think people are surprised.
Edward's really broken down to me.
Yeah.
I met him.
I was opening for Pauli do without doing that sketch movie that hurts you.
Yeah.
Take the condom off after you feel to feel dirty.
That uh,
that um,
comics natural born calm,
whatever the video was.
Let's hear the condom off.
Yeah.
And um,
oh that's better.
And you could see where you have to talk into too.
Fuck these.
But I saw him and he did the Orlando Improv and the Miami Improv mainstream
clubs and he was very funny.
Those clubs.
And then I heard it's going to the UCB on their big alternative night.
And I was like really performing.
They are,
cause I do it all the time.
I didn't know where you come from New York,
right.
Been there forever.
And I'm like,
well what,
what kind of material do you do it in front of the people?
And he stopped and he goes,
dude,
crowds is crowds.
It's true.
They don't care.
And I was like,
whoa.
But you know what?
A lot of people,
they do get a little elitist if they put them online and stuff.
Yeah.
But there's also crowd don't know if they figure,
if you're there,
you're supposed to be there.
And then we're like,
cool,
we'll laugh.
They don't really give a shit.
Yeah.
I don't know why anybody would restrict themselves to one time of comedy.
You know,
I've always been,
um,
a a fan.
I mean,
I think anybody who knows this podcast knows that I'm a fan of some pretty crazy
science and extraordinary ideas when it comes to quantum physics and the nature
of the universe and nature reality.
I like a lot of like pretty heady,
twisted up deep shit about just the very nature of matter itself.
But I love stupid comedy.
Yeah,
it's fun.
sure.
It's fun.
My first,
uh,
Mc week for this guy,
Brett leak.
Do you remember him?
Apparently I remember the [inaudible] muscular dystrophy and then it got like
worse and worse.
And he was a killer observational comic.
Oh really?
Oh,
probably 10,
15 times.
But he said it was him and then some lady who the relationship comedy in the
middle and then me being filthy,
I'm,
and he goes,
I like a different kind show.
Yeah.
So the DC Improv and he goes,
I like three different people's.
Nobody overlaps.
Yeah,
I agree,
man.
I,
I'm not,
I'm not into the same kind of comedy all the time.
I like a Mitch Hedberg.
It was like Wiki clean,
and then I'm like,
yeah,
I guess it was.
And then I like Joey Diaz talking about clean and I like Joey Diaz talking about
pinching a foil out of some girl.
That asshole he's bagging or the acid,
he felt foil at the tip of his dick foil.
So you reached him with his fingers,
pull it out,
put a desk.
He put his dick back here.
She's still craziest motherfucker of all time.
Every time I'm with him,
I just have this big smile.
Like I can't believe this guy is my friend.
He gets,
you're going,
oh,
this is what Burt said.
He was meeting him for coffee.
Right.
And he goes,
other people come up,
he takes,
he goes,
I think he just sits there all day long and like has people come meet him and
just throughout the day,
just sit in like an old Italian guy who was drinking coffee.
Bert Kreischer met.
Who?
Joey Diaz.
Oh,
where in the valley?
Somewhere for fucking knowhow.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
You know Joe,
he can't sit still for very long.
He's got shit to do.
Maybe he might've done it for him.
He takes his phone calls and he fucking not tax.
He didn't text me.
He calls he,
what'd you doing?
Okay.
The one minute phone calls.
He's a king of,
he's a legit businessman though,
that you got to think about that now.
Joey's guy like real money.
He's doing great on the road.
Chummy.
Joanie is killing them on the road.
And he convinced me to put my last storyteller show on online.
Yeah,
no,
it goes,
just put it just $2.
Throw it off.
It's beautiful.
Or you know,
seeing him get to number one on iTunes was fucking incredible.
He sold like 35 40,000 copies of that CD.
Just from self.
Yeah.
And by the way,
selling these testicle testaments,
he's still,
he's got other things on our tone where the chart fucking fantastic.
He doesn't know hour and a half to two hours of story on something every month.
And they're fucking tremendous and they're great.
If you're in your car and you're driving to work or something,
Oh God.
Slap one of those and you'll just have a big stupid smile on your face and half,
like really deep shit.
Yeah.
He's awesome.
It wasn't.
We're lucky,
man.
We're lucky.
We know a lot of comedians.
Yeah,
we are for sure.
Where you at this weekend?
I'm at a wedding.
Oh God.
I'm at the comedy store in the factory.
I'm to hide.
And Massachusetts.
Somebody made you go to across the country for their stupid fucking Buddhists,
the bride and the groom,
but
bring breast trips.
No,
I'm going to read marijuana.
A lot of marijuana.
I told them be on drugs on there and they're like,
well,
absolutely.
They knew it.
It's casual.
They knew that you were going to be high.
Yeah.
You're going to have an edible.
Probably not super strong.
I don't want to go.
I don't want to get bonkers,
but I want to get social anxiety and I don't want to fuck him.
Yeah.
How the social anxiety.
No,
that's,
if I don't go on something,
I'll have it.
Yeah.
You want to be high enough where it's cute,
I can relax.
Yeah.
You're like,
oh,
this is sweet.
Again,
if you don't cry when they say they're,
I'm a romantic.
Even when I'm believing that shit,
I'm still like some tugs at me when I see it once in your life.
Yeah.
No,
you are,
man.
You're a sweetie.
I've seen you with chicks to you're very affectionate guy.
A lot of people would think that our [inaudible] got a cold heart.
I'm not all dicks.
Nah,
he's just been batted around a few times and he's little,
little bruised in the answer.
Deep
inside.
Somebody asked me this recently,
they're like,
who hurts you?
And I will like,
oh,
all of them.
Every one of them.
Is that what you want to hear?
They all made me Eyeo.
Okay.
Write that down and say that on stage.
That's very important.
You need to write that down.
That's a bit.
Yeah.
Let's,
we'll get off the fucking podcast wondering no books.
Now it's to write down,
write down,
write down all of them who hurt you all a little bit.
Are you happy?
All of that.
All right.
You fucking dirty freaks tomorrow.
The Real Rick Ross and I'm Brian Red Ban will returns event for the Holocaust.
September 25th by that Shit.
You know what to do.
You freaks.
What is it?
How much is it a seven 99?
Jesus Christ.
Amen.
Itunes.
Go buy that shit.
Um,
uh,
and uh,
that's it.
The fucking shows over you freaks.
Thanks to what?
Oh,
thank you Marie.
Always.
Always good time man.
Thanks to ting.com shop ting.
Yeah,
we should.
Sorry Tang.
We kind of fucked here.
I'll help make it up.
I will give serious thought to tech.
I'm done with my fucking Verizon contract now and I was waiting for the new
iPhone to come out,
but if I get one of those Sam songs before they go off the market,
yeah,
get this before apple fucks them cause they're going to,
this thing is the shit man.
I'm,
it's really huge.
I'm enjoying the size,
like things sinner thinner than the iPhone.
Um,
yeah,
it's definitely thinner.
It's definitely thinner this way.
Yeah,
it's just wider.
I don't know anything about it.
Like battery life or anything.
You just got it.
Yeah,
I'm totally talking out of my ass.
I'm just right now I'm just like,
Ooh,
I've done nothing.
Go take your pissed son.
I haven't done nothing like where I could tell you that this was an awesome
device,
but it looks dope as fuck.
All right folks.
So go to a rogan.ting.com and um,
when you go there and you sign up,
you'll get a $50 credit towards a new device.
And,
uh,
like I said,
we were only supporting things on this show that we 100% believe in,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
going a death squad.
Dot TV and buying t shirts to support,
uh,
Brian Red Band and the podcast network.
Um,
whether it's,
uh,
to go to [inaudible] dot com and support them.
Ting is a,
as a company and we believe in that philosophy and,
uh,
we,
you know,
we were behind it a on it.com we're behind them 100%.
I'm,
I'm a part owner and on it because I love the philosophy behind the organization
and I love what the idea of selling things that I buy and things that I
absolutely 100%,
uh,
enjoy and benefit from like Alpha brain and shroom tech and new mood and hemp
force protein powder,
which is my favorite protein powder and earth and kettle bells and battle ropes,
which you know,
I do all day because I'm manly as fuck.
So I go to [inaudible] dot com that's o and n it.
And if you use the code name Rogan,
you will get 10% off any and all supplements and um,
that's it.
So,
uh,
go to desk squad.tv.
Go buy yourself some fucking shirts.
Uh,
go to higher primate.com if you want higher-primate.com.
That's my tee shirt company and I have a bunch of different tee shirts and
including a Joey Diaz.
If you're not high by two in the morning or two in the afternoon,
go fuck yourself tee shirt that's available at,
on it.
We just restocked.
And,
uh,
that money of course goes to a big part of it too.
The great one,
Joe Diaz.
So you're support is got a worst of the whites to shirt worst of the whites.
Yeah.
That's for you.
It should be the,
who would you say the Italians were the worst of the white version?
Armenians.
Persians.
I mean,
it's the worst.
The whites.
I don't think you want to make that in a tee shirt for him.
Fuck you up.
I Love Armenians,
man.
They will fuck you up while people,
yeah,
you need a better saying.
Yeah,
you,
we,
but,
but for you.
Yeah,
we definitely should put out in Arusha fierce to tee shirt.
What it should be.
If you're going to have an arch of here,
t shirt,
you must've said something fucked up.
You know what people contact us on Twitter.
Tell us the most fucked up thing.
Because sometimes people put things like in message board posts in quotes or on
Twitter.
Like what?
I completely forgot.
I said,
I write people.
What was the context?
Which is,
what was that about?
We look,
we appreciate the fuck out of it.
I,
um,
I say this all the time,
but I only say it because it's 100% true.
I,
the,
the thing that I am most blown away by is the amount of fucking cool people that
we meet at these shows.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
I,
um,
I don't understand it.
I don't,
uh,
I don't know how it all happened,
but,
uh,
I do know that a,
we're truly,
truly thankful and we had a lot of cool people,
I want to say humbled by it,
but is that is the word.
It's like,
whoa.
Like these are the,
this w everywhere we go,
everybody says the same thing.
These are the nicest crowds,
the most generous crowds.
Well,
again,
well in tip.
Well,
look,
we're,
we're happy as fuck that we're connecting with you guys like that.
And then every message that I get where people say,
hey man,
because of you,
I started drinking Kale shakes in the morning.
I lost 50 pounds.
I'm working out for the first time.
So I started [inaudible] like your,
the drive to not change.
And once you overcome like,
oh,
what am I,
what was that resistor?
Yeah.
What am I resisting?
And it's also having people in this conversation,
they tune in and they're a part of it,
even though they're not saying anything.
They might be saying something in their car.
They're like,
yeah,
fucking that fucking bitch.
You know that guy's an asshole.
There's a lot of people live in a town of 2000 and there's cool people there and
they're tuned into this and say,
oh,
find someone else's out there like this.
We recognize that this is an important part of your life.
This fucking show will always remain free.
This show will always remain completely uncensored.
If I tell you something,
it's because I believe it.
Even if I'm wrong,
I believe that shit.
Go to the Lobero theater this Saturday night or this Friday night in Santa
Barbara Duncan Trussell just add it to the show.
We are so not fucking around.
That is the Lobero Theater in Sacramento or in Santa Barbara or rather this
summit's call me.
Who the fuck is calling me?
Bob Fisher from the icehouse power VI's house.
Um,
so that's it folks.
We will see you tomorrow from the Ice House.
Ironically,
with the real Rick Ross on a.com,
use the code name rogue and go from,
by the way,
you guys,
the way you give back to us is by coming to our shows.
Yeah,
listen,
we'd love that you can ever go.
And the way though,
quite honestly,
that's a nice absolute benefit.
The biggest benefit for t for true is knowing the people are enjoying it.
You know,
when I run into people even at that,
that don't come to my shows.
If I run into with the mall or something like that,
and like,
dude,
I'm a huge podcast fan.
That makes me feel fucking great.
If you,
if I'm doing something and you're enjoying it,
I'm happy.
That's,
that's how I believe life should be.
All right.
You fucking freaks.
This show's over.
These loving mushrooms.
He's love mushrooms.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
I don't even have any chromatic going out,
right?
I don't even have any controversial.
Um,
I don't have any controversial sponsors anymore.
So when I end these things invade Argentina,
Argentina is filled with nice people.
Oh fuck man.
I don't know.
I'm trying to think.
Listen freaks,
we love you.
We love the shit out of you.
All right,
we'll see you soon.